entscheiden über die novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und dann geht
es rüber in den bundesrat und sie haben
gerade die massive kritik der
ministerpräsidenten was die hotspot
regelung vor allen dingen angeht ja
schon mitbekommen die
ministerpräsidenten das ist kein
johannes werden aber dennoch heute hier
im bundesrat gegenüber muss ich sagen
ich stehe im bundestag werden doch mit
stimmen denn sonst ist es ein
einspruchsgesetz müsste man den
vermittlungsausschuss dort anrufen und
dann würde das ganze so lange dauern
dass die übergangsregelungen die die
meisten länder ziehen wollen bis zum
zweiten april gar nicht mehr ziehen
würde alles ein wenig kompliziert zum
glück gibt es ja fachleute die sich da
sehr gut auskennen ich habe mir
eingeladen die beiden
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der fdp
und der cdu csu christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp und tino
sorge für die union frage - es ist ja
kein geheimnis die fdp hat dieses gesetz
eigentlich auch so ein bisschen gegen
die widerstände der koalitionspartner in
der ampel mit durchgesetzt ich darf
daran erinnern dass die spd vorsitzende
am mittwoch noch gesagt hat sie würde
sich wünschen dass die masken pflicht
auch allgemein in räumlichkeiten gilt
und herr damen das ist der
gesundheitspolitische experte der grünen
sagt dass es eigentlich ein must-have
dass wir das auch in diesem gesetz
verankern nun gab es ja noch mal
sitzungen was ist denn geändert worden
in diesen sitzungen ist die masken
pflicht in räumlichkeiten mit enthalten
sowie dass auch menschen der spd und
nicht unwichtige der grünen wollen nein
das nicht aber wir haben zum beispiel
die masken pflicht in arztpraxen
reingebracht also überall dort wo wohl
ne rabl gruppen sind da haben wir nach
gebessert aber wenn ich ihnen sagen die
allgemeine masken pflicht würde ja
bedeuten dass wir auch gerade in schulen
und kitas die masken pflicht beibehalten
sollten oder müssten und da sind wir
strikt dagegen und da sind wir uns einig
mit vielen kinderpsychologen kinder
ärzten mit fachleuten die sagen das geht
nicht denn omikron ist zwar hoch
ansteckend hat aber auch gerade bei
kindern ein sehr sehr milden verlauf und
insofern müssen wir schon
berücksichtigen was wir unseren kindern
antun sie sind schlechter beim lesen das
haben wir gerade jetzt festgestellt sie
haben psychische probleme und da müssen
wir doch mal genau hinschauen was wir
damit erreichen und deswegen haben wir
gesagt die wollen
da ist die masken pflicht wichtig aber
in anderen bereichen müssen wir sie
aufheben britta ernst das ist die
bildungsministerin aus brandenburg und
gleichzeitig die ehefrau des herrn
bundeskanzlers die hat gesagt sie wird
auf jeden fall bis zum zweiten april
gerade die masken pflicht auch bei den
kindern in den schulen durchsetzen denn
nur die maske hilft gegen ansteckungen
herr sorge scheint doch nicht so ganz
einheitlich in der ampel oder herr kuhn
ist genau das das problem dass man zwar
mit unterschiedlichen auffassungen sagen
kann wir sind für lockerungen oder wir
sind im team vorsicht aber das was jetzt
passiert ist eben ein mix aus beiden und
das erzeugt wird und wenn ich dann höre
dass er jetzt nachgebessert wurden
arztpraxen sind jetzt beispielsweise
enthalten zahnarztpraxen sind wieder
nicht drin physiotherapiepraxen sind
auch nicht mit enthalten also dann zeigt
das dass wir hier tatsächlich ein bürger
erzeugen und ich glaube es ist ja nur um
das alle ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder in der
mpk unisono sagen so geht das nicht das
wird dem nicht gerecht was wir wollen
als einen basisschutz einen
instrumentenkasten pandemie auch wenn
sie es verschlechtern sollte weiter
bekämpfen zu können und ich glaube das
sollte man als regierung auf sehr ernst
nehmen ja auch die virologen viele
virologen zumindest kritisieren dieses
gesetz mich als stürmer sagt zum
beispiel das aktuelle
infektionsgeschehen heute wieder ein top
wert wird von dieser ampel gar nicht
mehr zur kenntnis genommen
offensichtlich nicht mehr als maßstab
genommen sondern es geht eigentlich nur
um schnelle schnelle erleichterung und
lockerungen die infektionszahlen sollte
ja eigentlich schon lange nicht mehr der
maßstab sein wir waren uns von anfang an
einig dass wir eine überlastung der
intensivstation verhindern und durch
omikron haben wir eine andere situation
natürlich haben wir hohe
infektionszahlen aber schauen sie sich
mal an die intensivstationen heute zb
wieder immer jeden tag werden sie
weniger belegt und das zeigt doch dass
wir auch wieder lockerungen vornehmen
müssen und zwar in dem maße wie es
verantwortbar ist und wir sind der
meinung es ist verantwortbar in dem maße
weil wir eben wohl eine rabl gruppen
weiter schützen auch mit was masken
pflichten und ansonsten wir verbieten ja
nicht die masken ich bin ein großer
befürworter der masken aber uns wird
omicron noch sehr sehr lange
beschäftigen die nächsten jahre wir
müssen auch die eigenverantwortung der
menschen stärken und jeder kann für sich
selbst auch entscheiden ob er in
bestimmten situationen abstand halten
und maske tragen sollte ich werbe dafür
aber das kann man doch selbst
entscheiden und bitte nicht den kindern
weiter diese masken pflicht
aufoktroyieren die negativen
auswirkungen sind so immens das können
wir nicht weiter so fortführen da würde
ich ihn gerne vorlesen eine studie des
max planck institutes die hat nämlich
untersucht ft2 masken gesunde und ein
infizierter in einem raum da ist die
ansteckungsgefahren 0,1 prozent nach 20
minuten wenn zwei personen keine maske
tragen ist schon nach wenigen minuten
die andere person auch infiziert also
man kann ja nicht einfach sagen die
maske bringt nix auch bei kindern nicht
ich glaube ich habe mich missverstanden
ich habe niemals gesagt die maske bringt
nichts ich habe gerade eben betont sie
bringt sehr viel aber sie können doch
eigenverantwortlich die maske tragen und
wenn sie bei kindern so negative
auswirkungen hat sämtliche kinderärzte
und psychologen sagen kinder brauchen
auch um lesen zu lernen um soziales
verhalten zu haben müssen sie die mimik
sehen im gesicht das haben sie jetzt
seit zwei jahren nicht und das müssen
wir ändern weil bei kindern hat omikron
eben ein sehr sehr milden verlauf noch
milder als bei jungen erwachsenen
und da müssen wir schauen wo ist da die
linie die wir halten müssen ich verstehe
das argument meine kinder sind schon aus
dem haus ich habe großes verständnis für
kinder und ihre schwierigkeiten in
dieser phase der sorge und dennoch ist
es ja so im herbst haben wir das gesehen
dass gerade durch die schulkinder auch
bei uns im team die mütter wurden krank
die väter auch die kleine kinder hatten
weil da wird sich natürlich weiter
gegeben wir haben hunde ist das ja nur
ein teilbereich den wir diskutieren das
was das gesetz leider nicht erfüllt ist
eine klarheit also das gesetz ist eine
einziger unbestimmter rechtsbegriff wir
haben ja bei der frage beispielsweise
wann brauchen wir auch verschärfungen
bei der masken pflicht wieder stichwort
wenn eine neue virusvariante auftritte
wird im gesetz definiert wenn eine
höhere pathogenität ist also höhere
krankheitslast das wird nicht klar
definieren also keiner weiß wie das
konkret vor ort ausgelegt werden soll da
gibt es ja auch im dissens zwischen dem
bundesjustizminister der genau sagt das
ist anders verstehen als der
bundesgesundheitsminister wir haben das
problem bei der frage der hotspots
regelungen das heißt was kann ein sports
sein wir haben das bei der frage
drohende krankenhaus überlassung also
das sind viele dinge einfach überhaupt
nicht geklärt da gibt es viel spielraum
und das ist ja auch das was wir und
unisono die länder kritisieren dass sie
sagen der basisschutz der werkzeugkasten
um eben schnell reagieren zu können also
beispielsweise auch in innenräumen wenn
sich die infektions lage verschärft der
wird mit diesem gesetz nicht erreicht
und deshalb kann man wirklich nur sagen
der gesetzentwurf das sagen wir auch
schon die kolleginnen und kollegen aus
den ländern der muss nachgebessert
werden und das noch vor der
verabschiedung das ist glaube ich ein
warnsignal an die regierungen das sollte
man ernst nehmen frauen dagegen dass ich
fange mal ganz grundsätzlich an die wenn
die hospitalisierung nicht mehr der
maßstab ihres gesetzes ist welche
maßstäbe legen sie denn dann an ich habe
gesagt die hospitalisierung also die
zahl derjenigen menschen die auf
intensivstationen liegen das ist der
maßstab den wir wollen ja die
überlastung des gesundheitswesens
reduzieren beziehungsweise gar nicht
erst aufkommen lassen insofern ist die
inzidenz also die infektionszahlen ist
nicht der maßstab da waren wir
eigentlich schon vor monaten so weit
dass wir das wussten jetzt wird
komischerweise immer nur auf die
inzidenz zahlen geschaut das hat heute
zum beispiel auch der vorsitzende des
hausärzteverbandes herr waigel
kritisiert der sagte wir zwitschern
immer von den verschiedenen systemen hin
und her mal geht es um die inzidenz mal
geht es um die zahl der
intensivpatienten das verwirrt die
menschen auch ich bin der meinung und
mit vielen experten und schon seit
monaten dass die zahl der intensiv
medizinisch behandelten das kriterium
ist und die steigt nicht trotz der hohen
infektionszahlen schmeckt und was fällt
sind die leute die sich um diese
intensiv patienten kümmern können und da
gab es gestern bei den
ministerpräsidenten auch schon
interessante diskussion ob zum beispiel
demnächst pfleger und krankenschwestern
die erkrankt sind aber keine symptome
mehr zeigen ob die nicht gleich dann
wieder in den dienst gehen können ja
natürlich ist jetzt durch diese hohe
infektionszahlen sind viele ausfälle in
den bereichen aber sie müssen ja auch
sagen wer doppelt geimpft und gebucht
hat ist überträgt das virus ja auch eine
ganz kurze zeit mehr und ist auch vor
einem schweren verlauf geschützt
deswegen haben wir ja auch für impfungen
und postern aber selbstverständlich ist
es bei der kritischen infrastruktur so
das durch die infektionen da auch
ausfälle sind und entsprechend muss man
dann reagieren aber wir müssen doch
jetzt nicht sämtliche maßnahmen
verschärfen weil das bringt in dem fall
ja nichts sie wissen ja dass sehr viele
doppelt geimpft und gewusst hätte auch
an um ikon erkranken ja und das ist ja
das verwirrende am anfang hat man
gedacht ich lass mich jetzt impfen ich
lasse mich boostern alles wird gut und
das ist ja leider gar nicht so nochmal
was wirklich schützt das zeigt zum
beispiel auch das geschehen karneval in
köln kann man gut nachweisen was
wirklich schützt wären masken denn da
ist jede instanz riesig hoch gegangen
obwohl alle leute die in den kneipen
gefeiert haben mindestens geimpft oder
gemustert waren ist die instanz riesig
explodiert also noch mal impfen und
mustern ist eigentlich keine lösung für
die menschen die sich auf keinen fall
anstecken dürfen nämlich die berühmten
wohl ne rebellengruppen die die fdp
eigentlich immer in altersheime und
krankenhäuser verband dabei laufen
tausende durch die gegend die zum
beispiel krebs infiziert sind ich selber
bin schwerer asthmatiker bin gut
eingestellt aber ich möchte es nicht
kriegen also im grunde ist das genau der
punkt dass man einerseits sagt wir
müssen stärker auf eigenverantwortung
setzen aber in den bereichen in räume
haben sie angesprochen oder da wo andere
gruppen auch zusammenkommen dass man da
durchaus über solche maßnahmen
nachdenken muss aber was wir tatsächlich
was wir tatsächlich kritisieren ist die
frage wie können diese massnahme
angeordnet werden und das ist ja im
gesetz so unklar geregelt also besteht
ja auch noch der streit in wie weit
können die länder das anordnen also die
landesparlamente sollen jetzt solche
massnahmen anordnen also muss das
parlament im land jetzt jede einzelne
maßnahme anordnung also es ist viel zu
unklar viel zu diffus und insofern
glaube ich auch sollten wir uns auch in
anderen ländern mal ein beispiel nehmen
wenn ich mir angucke die schweiz
österreich alle keine masten vielleicht
genau das sagen im moderaten bereich
also stichwort pflegeheime
beispielsweise in den strassen bahn also
da wo viele menschen aufeinander treffen
masten pflicht ja auch unter
berücksichtigung der inzidenz werte und
krankenhaus auslastung aber darüber
hinaus klare regelung wenn sich lage
verschärft muss man dann reagieren
können genau das steht doch in unserem
infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt drin dass
die wohl gerade in gruppen eine maske
nicht haben der zum beispiel auch testen
können auch in kitas und schulen
das ist doch gerade der bereich der
geschützt moment alle das europäische
ausland ich kann ihn die ganzen länder
aufzählen die haben alle keine masken
pflicht mehrere ohne also ausnahme ist
der pnv in der schweiz und auch da haben
wir eine masken pflicht also genau das
was herr sorge eben angemahnt hat genau
das setzen wir gerade um aber fragen
kommen wir noch auf die wollen raten
gehoben noch mal die sind ja nicht
weggeschlossen die bewegen sich in
unserer gesellschaft zum beispiel in
geschäften und sie sagen in geschäften
soll keine maske mehr getragen werden
und der bundeswehr
bundesgesundheitsminister hat gestern im
zdf noch mal betont er rechnet mit einer
wesentlich höheren infektionszahlen im
sommer als es zum beispiel im letzten
jahr der fall war das ist doch einfach
unverantwortlich gegenüber den bullen
gruppen die gerade sie von der fdp mann
schützen war ja die wollen wir auch
schützen deswegen machen wir es ja dort
wo die sich nicht selbst schützen können
per gesetz aber dort wo man sich selbst
schützen kann mit so einer fft zwei
maske sind sie wenn sie richtig tragen
geschützt und ich weiß es genau aus den
einzelnen kommunen es gibt wunderbare
projekte wenn sie zum beispiel einen
bereich hamburg viele ältere menschen
sind da gibt es speziell einkaufszeiten
in den lebensmittelgeschäften vertrauen
wir doch auch mal auf die kreativität
der bürgerinnen und bürger vertrauen wir
doch auch mal darauf dass sie sich
richtig verhalten nach zwei jahren
pandemie und nicht immer nur
staatlicherseits alles vorschreiben ich
glaube die menschen wissen am besten wie
sie sich zu schützen haben versorge guck
mir noch mal ganz schnell auf das
verfahren vorgestern die erste lesung
heute die zweite dritte gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat die fdp
in oppositionszeiten ja immer kritisiert
dass die regierung sich mit den
ministerpräsidenten einig und ich hab so
ein bisschen das gefühl dass die ampel
in dem fall der bundesjustizministerin
hat jetzt machen was man genau umgekehrt
was bedeutet das denn unterm strich die
ministerpräsidenten müssen das gesetz
durchführen in ihren ländern die
maßstäbe sind unklar sie haben schon
zwei mal angesprochen und vor allem
können sie heute im bundesrat im grunde
genommen gar nicht ablehnen was heißt
denn das für das demokratische
zusammenspiel zwischen bund und ländern
aber ich finde es ist ein tiefpunkt im
parlamentarischen zusammenspiel das muss
man sagen wir haben ja nicht nur diese
enge beratungs folge sondern werden
haben wir hatten ja auch das novum dass
wir die anhörung zu diesem gesetz noch
vor der ersten lesung gemacht haben also
normalerweise hat man erste lesung dann
geht es in die anhörung dann kommen zwei
drittel lösung
das jetzt zu schnell entschieden werden
muss das kommt ja mit ansage also seit
monaten ist klar dass ab dem 19 ab dem
20 märz die maßnahmen auslaufen wenn es
keine neuregelung gibt oder verlängerung
das wusste die ampelkoalition sie haben
nichts getan und jetzt haben wir das
problem dass die ministerpräsident mehr
oder weniger sagen friss oder stirb das
heißt sie haben vorhin angesprochen wenn
nicht zugestimmt wird heute im bundesrat
dann gibt es ein noch größeres wirrwarr
und deshalb kann man sagen na ja es ist
schlecht gemacht das gesetz
handwerkliche mängel zu vage aber es ist
besser als gar nichts aber das kann
natürlich nicht sinn und zweck der
ganzen parlamentarischen übung sein
frauchen ergebnis um den armen zu
schließen sie haben das angesprochene
europäischen ausland wird auch so
verfahren das würde ja bedeuten in der
diskussion die wir auch haben um eine
impfpflicht in deutschland kann auf
keinen fall eine impfpflicht kommen denn
die meisten länder im europäischen
ausland haben keine helmpflicht und weiß
ich dass sie auch nicht in der pflicht
sind aber die mehrheit ihrer ampel
kollegen ja zb und kolleginnen also das
argument ist auch übrigens ich als vater
haben dass in der erziehung auch nie
benutzen nur weil andere etwas machen
mache ich es auch das finde ich ein
recht schwaches argument nein das ist ja
auch nicht das argument ich bin gegen
eine impfpflicht aber dafür dass die
menschen dazu gebracht werden sich
impfen zu lassen und zwar durch
aufklärung und wir wissen es wir haben
nicht nur die impfgegner wir haben viele
menschen die angst haben vor der impfung
denen kann man die ängste nehmen und wir
werben ja für das impfen aber durch
zwang sehen wer ist es nicht umsetzbar
und wir tun immer alle so wenn wir die
impfpflicht hätten werden sofort alle
geimpft stimmt ja nicht und die
maßnahmen die dazu führen sind alle
nicht durchdacht vielen dank dass die
beiden da waren drin geht es nämlich los
und in den vorsitz hat herr petra pau
neben katrin göring eckardt die 1
bundestags-vizepräsidentin die hier den
dienst versehen kann seit zwei tagen die
anderen sind mich erkrankt die meisten
von den anderen ancona dich geh bereit
während japan geht manchmal dienstag den
märz 2022
bis freitag den 25 märz 2022 wie üblich
keine befragung der bundesregierung
keine fragestunde und auch keine
aktuellen stunden durchzuführen sind sie
damit einverstanden
dass ist der offenkundig der fall dann
verfahren gesucht als präsenztage nach §
14 absatz 1 des abgeordnetengesetzes
werden die tage von montag dem 21 märz
bis freitag den 25 märz 2022
festgelegt
wir haben außerdem jetzt eine wahl
durchzuführen
auf vorschlag der fraktion der cdu/csu
soll der kollege friedrich merz als
nachfolger
führen den kollegen ralph brinkhaus als
stellvertretendes mitglied des
ausschusses
nach artikel 77 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes
des vermittlungsausschusses gewählt
ich sehe keinen widerspruch
dann ist der kollege friedrich merz als
stellvertretendes mitglied des
vermittlungsausschusses
gewählt
auf verlangen der fraktion der afg wird
heute als letzter punkt der tagesordnung
eine aktuelle stunde stattfinden mit dem
thema haltung der bundesregierung zu den
vorwürfen gegen einen spiegel im
zusammenhang mit der flutkatastrophe
2021 soweit die mitteilungen vor
eintritt in die tagesordnung ich rufe
auf die tagesordnungspunkte
21 a bis 21 so wie die zusatzpunkte
15 17 und 18 beratung mehrere vorlagen
zu einer bedingten regelungen zur
dritten beratung des gesetzentwurfs zur
rettung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
liegen ein entschließungsantrag
der fraktionen der afd sowie ein
entschließungsantrag der fraktion die
linke vor über diesen gesetzentwurf
werden wir später namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen bevor ich die
aussprache eröffnet sei mir der hinweis
gestattet sie dürfen auch heute mit der
kollegin katrin göring eckardt und mit
mir hier vorlieb nehmen und wir bleiben
dankeschön
wir bleiben bei den regelungen die wir
seit mittwoch hier praktizieren
natürlich ist das fragerecht und
bemerkung recht gewährleistet
aber es gibt kein natürliches recht auf
kurzinterventionen wenn eine frage
abgewiesen wurde sondern wir fahren dann
in den beratungen fort
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
der bundesminister herr lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die panne mädels leider noch
nicht vorbei und wir brauchen weitere
schutzmaßnahmen und um solche zu
beschließen sind wir heute
zusammengekommen wir haben viel
geschafft aber wir sind nicht an dem
punkt wo schon an freedom day kommen
könnte wir sind heute nicht
zusammengekommen über den frieden zu
sprechen und frieden wäre auch nicht das
ende der schutzmaßnahmen der federnde
wäre das ende der pandemie und den
vielen ideen besprechen wir somit nicht
heute den frieden die haben wir gestern
gesprochen denn unseren frieden de
können wir erreichen wenn wir diese
pandemie beenden indem wir die
allgemeine impfpflicht beschließen das
ist der einzige sichere weg aus der
familie heraus wir können die nicht zu
schließen indem wir einfach die
schutzmaßnahmen einstellen wir brauchen
dich schutz maßen solange wir die hohe
zahl von ungeimpften haben daran muss
immer wieder erinnert werden und wir
wären schon viel weiter als wir sind
wenn uns dies gelingen könnte
wenn wir
werden wir uns heute die zahlen
anschauen fast 300.000 fälle werden wir
uns heute die todeszahlen anschauen über
200 menschen sind gestorben das kann uns
nicht zufriedenstellen das ist extrem
unbefriedigend dazu kommt die deutsche
sonderrolle die über 60 jährigen zu
einem hohen maß
um games viel mehr als in unseren
nachbarländern und wir haben darüber
hinaus eine relativ alte bevölkerung
daher brauchen wir schutzmaßnahmen
schutzmaßnahmen die in anderen ländern
in diesem umfang nicht mehr notwendig
sind
ich finde es ich muss das haben was
sagen ich finde es traurig wenn wir über
so ein wichtiges thema sprechen und wir
müssen uns an diese zeit diese
niederträchtigen unterstellungen und ein
so verhandlung das ist einfach schlicht
eine störung ich finde ich mache ich
komme damit gut zurecht ich komme noch
nicht gut zur welt aber ich es spricht
wohnen der bedeutung der fragen die wir
hier debattieren die ernsthaftigkeit wir
können hier unterschiedlicher man sein
und wir werden auch straße wir werden in
der sache streiten wir werden denn das
lachen stand aber die ernsthaftigkeit
dieser debatte wird von ihnen in abrede
gestellt das können wir nicht hinnehmen
das ist eine art das ist eine
unglaubliche
verhöhnung der opfer sind wir und ich
bin ich noch einmal ich möchte noch
etwas sagen wir sprechen heute über
einen schweren kompromiss das ist aber
nicht der kompromiss das ist nicht der
kompromiss über den wir heute sprechen
zwischen team freiheit und team vorsicht
sondern wir sprechen heute über einen
kompromiss was können wir den menschen
noch zumuten wie sich alt ist an die
regeln halten die unsere kinder was was
können wir den menschen noch zumuten die
regeln beachten und was sind wir bereits
denjenigen zuzumuten wie gar nichts
bereits so sind so auch von die sich
nicht eingelassen wort redet was nicht
sind die ausfuhren keinen einzigen
konstruktiven beitrag im verlaufe der
gesamten fanden bisher haben lassen kann
ich sage dass ich weiß dass ich als
epidemiologe gewünscht hätte wir hätten
mehr für diejenigen touren können sie
jetzt im risiko steht aber wir müssen
die rechtliche lage brach um die
rechtliche lage ist die wir können nicht
weiter das gesamte land unter schutz
stellen um eine kleine gruppe von
impfwilligen
und denjenigen die beraten nicht bereit
sind die massnahmen mitzutragen um diese
zu schützen die balance ist geändert das
muss ich wenn
herr doktor lauterbach ich habe die zeit
angehalten ich bitte sie einen kleinen
moment innezuhalten
und ich sage es heute morgen nur ein
einziges mal
es gilt die allgemeinverfügung und das
heißt die masken können zur rede am pult
beziehungsweise hier oben für die
präsidentinnen abgesetzt werden
für zwischenrufe gilt die masken
es werden in den wenigen minuten die wir
jetzt hier beisammen sind jetzt mehrfach
verstöße auf der rechten seite des
hauses gegen die allgemeinverfügung
und ich werde
entsprechend unseren regelungen dies
hier auch nachdrücklich an ich bitte
darum dass zu beachten sollte
irgendjemand aus welchen gründen auch
immer hier nicht im saal verweilen
können und die maske weitertragen können
dann muss er bitte die debatte
anderweitig verfolgen
sie haben wieder das wort herr minister
laut die regelungen die wir heute
vorstellen ist eine regelung die
folgenden der tatsache rechnung stellt
wir haben durch die omikron variante
nicht mehr die situation dass das
gesamte land gefährdet ist in dem sinne
dass wir eine überlastung dass wir eine
überlastung der kliniken dass wir eine
überlassung der kliniken flächendeckend
zu befürchten haben trotzdem würde es so
sagen dass in vielen stellen tatsächlich
genau diese überlastung kommen wird und
da haben wir die regeln angepasst dass
überall dort wo wir eine überlassung der
krankenhäuser und der
gesundheitsversorgung erwarten müssen
dass dort die hotspot regelung zieht und
wir werden auch weitergehende maßnahmen
ergreifen können und wo das nicht der
fall ist würde es nicht gemacht darauf
haben wir uns angepasst hätten wir dies
nicht gemacht hätten wir keine regeln
mehr gehalt denn dann ist es entweder
die möglichkeit gegeben wir machen die
regeln überall überall maßnahmen auch
dort wo es keine überlastung gibt das
wäre rechtlich nicht gegangen oder
hätten gangs auf die regeln verzichtet
frieden gehen dann hätten wir gar nichts
gab somit ist die begrenzung der regeln
auf die teile deutschlands wo
tatsächlich die überlastung zu
befürchten ist das ist der richtige
kompromiss und das ist ein kompromiss
das ist nicht frei hat gegen vorsicht
sondern das trägt einfach der tatsache
rechnung dass wir sie überhaupt noch
zielgerecht reagieren können und da
bitte ich um ihr vertrauen wir werden
das so setzen die landtage werden das
auch umsetzen können und wo ein ganzes
land betroffen ist das sind herr
buschmann und ich auch einer man das
würde immer falsch lag ich wo ein ganzes
land hotspot ist da kann das ganz
langsam auch als hotspot gelten das ist
zum beispiel etwas was jetzt auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern
getestet wird somit wir brauchen hier
vertrauen wir brauchen funktionierende
regeln ich bitte sie diesem gesetz
zuzustimmen es wird uns für die nächsten
monate wenn die lage sich verändert wenn
wir andere varianten zu bekommen werden
die gesundheitsversorgung stärker
gefährdet ist wenn wir beispielsweise
eine gefährliche variante bekommen dann
wird zunächst einmal dieses gesetz aber
dann sind wir auch bereit jederzeit das
infektionsschutzgesetz
erneut anzupassen um dieser neuen lage
rechnung zu tragen
ja das war offensichtlich schon das ende
des der rede des ministers ja viele
waren überrascht dass ausgerechnet karl
lauterbach vom team vorsichtig in das
team freiheit gewechselt ist gemeinsam
mit dem bundesjustizminister der fdp ein
buschmann hat er dieses werk vorgelegt
und jetzt hier bei der heutigen heute
noch mal betont wir können auch die
jederzeit wieder zu anderen maßnahmen
zurückkehren der nächste redner in der
debatte ist der gesundheitspolitische
sprecher der cdu csu tino sorge
kolleginnen und kollegen das gesetz was
wir heute hier abschließend debattieren
hatte zwei klare aufgaben erste aufgabe
lockerungen verantwortungsbewusst für
das frühjahr vorbereiten die zweite
aufgabe absicherung dafür her zu stellen
falls ich die infektions lage
verbessert oder verschlechtert
beides leistet das gesetz nicht viel
mehr erzeugt dass ein bürger und dieses
wird das haben nicht nur kritisiert
sondern auch alle ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer und
ich finde das schon bemerkenswert der
kollege lauterbach wenn sie sich hier
hinstellen und sagen in der koalition
sei einigkeit darüber erzeugt wurden was
spots sind also ich habe jetzt ihren
bundesjustizminister nicht klatschen
sehen weil der sieht das offensichtlich
ganz anders als sie was ein hotspot sein
kann also insofern
sie ist schon nicht einig sind dann
müssen sie sich nicht wundern wenn die
länder nicht wissen wie sie das umsetzen
und ich kann ihnen ganz klar sagen wir
haben ja gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der länder
gehabt es ist ein absolutes novum in der
geschichte dass 16 ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten dieser
bundesrepublik deutschland in
protokollerklärungen sagen dass das so
nicht geht dass das wirrwarr erzeugt
dass die ampel auf rot gelb grün steht
und im grunde das chaos mit ansage ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
ich könnte es mir ich könnte es mir sehr
sehr einfach waren ich müsste haben
grunde bloß diese protokolle erklärung
vorlegen deshalb habe ich sie mir hier
noch mal mitgebracht ich lese mal die
ersten beiden punkte vor dieser
protokolle erklärung in top 6 da sagen
zahlreiche bundesländer
die länder bedauern dass die geplante
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
weitestgehend ohne beteiligung der
länder konzipiert worden sind obwohl die
länder maßgeblich für den vollzug
zuständig sind erster punkt weiterer
punkt die nunmehr durch den bund
angestrebte änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes bleibt hinter
diesem schutzniveau zurück zudem ist die
vorgesehene hotspot regelung regelung
rechtlich nicht sicher umsetzbar und
praktisch nicht durchsetzbar liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und der frage
ist sich allen ernstes was wollen sie
mit diesem gesetz erreichen glauben sie
ernsthaft dass wir mit diesem gesetz
rechtssicherheit in den ländern erzeugen
die kolleginnen und kollegen
und das was sie hier gesagt haben herr
kollege laute was ist ja dass sie
definieren wie dieser instrumentenkasten
aussehen könnte und die bundesländer
haben gesagt wir brauchen einen
instrumentenkasten der ihm genau auf
diese dynamische lage reagieren lassen
kann sie haben definiert höhere
pathogenität also wenn ein virus mit
einer höheren pathogenität sich zeigt
dass man dann schneller reagieren kann
muss was sie nicht definieren ist was
ist höhere pathogenität sie sagen in
bereichen wo besonders hohe neue
infektionen kommen kann reagiert werden
keiner weiß was meint sie mit besonders
hohem neuinfektionen und die drohende
klinik überlastung im hinblick auf die
hotspots das ist genau der punkt der
maßgebliche punkt dem sie innerhalb der
koalition nicht geklärt haben der
kollege lauterbach und da ist sollten
sie dringend nacharbeiten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
kann ich ihnen nur sagen wir werden
dieses gesetz ablehnen nicht nur weil es
handwerklich schlecht ist weil es in den
einzelheiten nicht geklärt dass sein
einziger unscharfer rechtsbegriff ist
wir werden es als opposition ablehnen
aber auch ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
in den ländern frau die wie
beispielsweise hat gestern ja schon
angekündigt noch vor verabschiedung des
gesetzes dass nachgebessert werden muss
also insofern gehe ich davon aus dass
wir uns sehr zeitnah wieder sind wir
vielen dank
timo sorge war dass die cdu/csu wird
dieses gesetz als handwerklich schlecht
gemachtes gesetz ablegen ablehnen
besonders kritisierte sorge die hotspot
regelung zucken klare definitionen das
gleiche taten ja die
ministerpräsidenten gestern
pisten runter letzte vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses von den gästen
als nächstes
[Applaus]
heute reden sollen doch auf ihn hat als
bewohner virus erwischt dass er dafür
spott und häme
vier sofort und auch im netz ab bekommt
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
unerträglich
dass reine theorie plätze fragt was sie
hier machen lieber ja noch unsere volle
solidarität
es ist unerträglich am menschen sind
krank und er ist einer von etwa 300.000
menschen die sich derzeit täglich neu
infizieren und wir wünschen allen von
ihnen einen milden verlauf
doch leider doch leider liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wissen wir dass
es jeden tag auch menschen schwer trifft
das über 200 menschen täglich sterben
und longo witt jeden und jede treffen
kann auch kinder wir dürfen longo witt
nicht unterschätzen
und bei der frage auf unser
gesundheitssystem überlastet ist sollten
wir nicht nur auf die intensivstation
gucken die peripheren stationen der
krankenhäuser sind zurzeit stark unter
druck alle kolleginnen und kollegen dort
herzlich aus der pflege alle arbeiten am
limit und überall sind die menschen in
unserem land unter druck auch psychisch
und der ton verschärft sich nicht nur
hier auch sonst aber wir können diese
pandemie nur gemeinsam überwinden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]
und auch in keiner
koalition ist es in unserer demokratie
notwendig kompromisse zu finden
das ist das wesen der demokratie
aus meiner sicht als ärztin als
gesundheitspolitikerin aus meiner
fraktion und im übrigen auch der
mehrheit der bevölkerung braucht es für
einen guten infektionsschutz vermutlich
mehr als das was heute in diesem gesetz
vorliegt ff
wir wissen dass er fit wie zwei masken
einen guten schutz vor ansteckung bieten
und es wäre gut weiterhin präventiv zu
agieren und die masken pflicht
flächendeckend beizubehalten
und es ist kein geheimnis dass wir auch
innerhalb der koalition unterschiedliche
positionen dazu hatten welche maßnahmen
jetzt bundesweit weiterhin nötig sind
aber
kein gesetz wäre sehr viel schlechter
gewesen als dieses gesetz was ja
weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen beinhaltet
und darum werden wir als bündnis 90 die
grünen auch zustimmen auch wenn wir uns
deutlich mehr gewünscht hätten weil das
ist das was innerhalb der ampel
vereinbar war und worst case wäre
gewesen alle schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen
zu lassen
hier also mit diesem gesetz schützen wir
natürlich mehr als ohne gesetz hier ist
der spatz in der hand natürlich deutlich
mehr schutz als die taube auf dem dach
ich hoffe sehr
dass die mast und riecht aber auch die
masten für weiter benutzt wird und zwar
nicht nur für sich selbst sondern auch
für andere besonders verletzliche
personen wert diese schützen möchte
trägt in diesem frühjahr weiter masken
beispielsweise im supermarkt denn dort
kaufen menschen ein mit kleinen kindern
menschen die sich nicht impfen lassen
konnten bisher und auch diese sind auf
unsere solidarität angewiesen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
worauf die länder kommt jetzt eine große
verantwortung zu sie können die
übergangsfrist bis zum 2 april
verlängern sie können schutzmaßnahmen
fortführen und von der hotspot regelung
gebrauch machen viele länder wie bremen
berlin baden württemberg schon in diese
richtung dass es vermutlich sehr klug
und klar bleibt wenn die neuen maßnahmen
nicht ausreichen werden müssen wir
nachsteuern
denn diese pandemie ist noch nicht
vorbei und wir werden sie nur gemeinsam
gesagt man hat sich gebeugt den willen
der fdp werden hampels lieben noch klare
aussage von juliane stammen ist
erkrankten gewissen von hier genau wie
zum beispiel die bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas der bundestags- vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki aydan özoguz alle an
corona erkrankt und mit ihnen zusammen
fast 300.000 bundesbürger am heutigen
tage rekord glänzen und der bundestag
und der bundesrat r lockern die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen die nächste
rednerin kommt von der art wie christina
bleiben wollen ist nichts weiter als
eine beruhigungspille
denn die wenigen erleichterungen können
jederzeit aufgehoben werden ganz nach
lust und laune da es keine eindeutigen
parameter für die hotspots gibt die
korona maßnahmen gehören schon deshalb
komplett vom tisch weil das darf der
erhobene kriterium zu keinem zeitpunkt
erfüllt war zu keinem zeitpunkt gab es
eine überlastung der krankenhäuser oder
der intensivstationen
es passierte studien zur wirksamkeit der
korona maßnahmen gibt es nicht deren
schädlichkeit ist jedoch hinlänglich
bewiesen
insbesondere bei kindern und
jugendlichen haben sie zu massiven
körperlichen und psychischen schäden
geführt endlichkeit depressionen es und
sprach sprachstörung bis hin zu
generellen entwicklungsstörungen all das
ist jedoch nur die spitze des eisberges
das tragen von masken führt zu einem
anstieg von blutdruck und herzfrequenz
kopfschmerzen schwindel
konzentrationsschwäche und
hautirritationen wie in einer metastudie
zum masken induzierten
erschöpfungssymptomen beschrieben wurde
ich zitiere aus einer stellungnahme bei
einer öffentlichen sitzung der
kinderschutz kommission des deutschen
bundestages am 19 september 2020 von
professor doktor michael klundt zitat
alle entscheidungen und maßnahmen der
politik seit märz april 2020 wurden
völkerrechts verstoßen und bundesgesetze
wie trick ohne vorrangige
berücksichtigung des kindeswohls
vorgenommen der kindeswohl vorrang ist
nicht nur ignoriert worden sondern aus
dem kinderschutz wurde plötzlich der
schutz von kindern
sie wurden als viren verbreitet wie
objekte behandelt diese instrumente
behandlung von kindern betrachte ich als
eine form von kindeswohlgefährdung sie
tag ändern
rechtsprofessor und damit hatte beweist
ein corona szenarien papier des
bundesministeriums für märz 2020 darin
können sie auf seite 13 lesen um die
gewünschte schockwirkung zu erzielen
müssen die konkreten auswirkungen einer
durchsuchung auf die menschliche
gesellschaft verdeutlicht werden und
unter punkt 2 steht dass man kindern die
schuld dafür geben sollen dass ihre
eltern anstecken die dann qualvoll zu
hause sterben das sei der schrecklichste
was ein kind je erleben könnte dies
dieses unmenschliche leider sind kinder
damit zugefügt wurde wird für immer mit
ihrem namen verbunden sein doch nicht
nur die kinder sind geschädigt sondern
die ganze gesellschaft als soziale wesen
sind wir auf kontakte umarmungen und
näher angewiesen sie haben diese
menschliche nur bedürfnisse verboten und
mit welchem ergebnis
die im sidenten sind so hoch wie nie
allein das zeugt von der völligen
unwirksamkeit aller maßnahmen das
einzige was sie damit erreicht haben ist
die schwächung der eigenen immunabwehr
wir brauchen für ein funktionierendes
immunsystem den kontakt mit viren wir
brauchen die bewegung an der frischen
luft wir brauchen sauerstoff zum atmen
und wir brauchen liebevolle umarmungen
wären sie unserem volk er ist ein
menschenwürdiges leben und lebensfreude
zurück das ist die beste medizin
vielen dank
christine baum war das von der htgf die
bringt ihr einen antrag ein in dem sie
fordert alle kohler maßnahmen für kinder
sofort beenden und wenn man mal hinten
liest was der
bundestag beschließen soll dann kommt da
eine sehr witzige passagen unter punkt 3
fordert die fdp eine sondersitzung des
bundestages einzige rechnet in der die
bundesregierung die kinder um verzeihung
bittet lukas kohler jetzt stellte
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
herr sorge ich habe mich überrascht dass
sie so sehr auf die klare und eindeutige
einhaltung des blinden folgen quasi der
mpk wochen würden ich kann mich daran
erinnern dass auch dieses mal einstimmig
alle ministerpräsidenten für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht gestimmt haben
und ich wäre würde mich wundern ob die
cdu nach den vorträgen von gestern die
csu dem auch so folgen würde das wäre
doch eine ganz andere die waffenlager
habe ich wäre vorsichtig mit den
forderungen die man aussieht ich glaube
aber und ich will ihnen das gar nicht
das zeigt ja eine sache wir sind
lernfähig wir entwickeln uns weiter
während wir unser wissen weiter und ich
glaube das ist auch das was man in
dieser pandemie sieht dass wir in der
diskussion die wir hier führen sehen und
das ist auch das was wir in den
richtigen und notwendigen maßnahmen
sehen die wir zum schutz
sehen müssen denn meine damen und herren
die nicht die freiheit von
einschränkungen des begründung bedürftig
die einschränkung der freiheit ist
begründung bedürftig und das müssen wir
bei jeder bei jeder einzelnen maßnahme
die wir treffen immer wieder vor augen
haben wir müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir politik so ausgestalten dass
nur das an den wenigen freiheits
einschränkungen möglich ist das
notwendig ist und das ist das was wir
mit diesem gesetzesentwurf das ist das
was wir mit diesem vorschlag wir
schützen auf der einen seite sorgen aber
dafür dass wir so weit wie es irgendwie
geht zurück zur normalität kommen
die herausforderung vor der wir stehen
ist natürlich dass sich pandemie
geschehen das sich aber auch wissen
entwickelt und so war es ja ganz klar
dass vor dem schleier der unwissenheit
am anfang der pandemie entscheidung
getroffen worden bei denen wir heute
sagen sie waren damals falsch oder
unnötig aber zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie
getroffen wurden hätten wir sie nicht
anders treffen können und deswegen haben
wir als freie demokraten
damals schon unterstützt in einer ganz
anderen koalition und auch konstellation
wir haben aber gesehen dass sich diese
pandemie verändert wir haben gesehen
dass wir immense infektionszahlen haben
dass wir eine sehr hohe instituts haben
aber dass die incidents heute nicht mehr
der ausschlaggebende faktor
einzig und allein die überlastung der
krankenhäuser ist es was wir politisch
betrachten müssen was jetzt in zukunft
die landtage beachten müssen und nicht
die frage inwiefern es funktionieren
kann dass wir immer weitere instanzen
immer unterschiedlicheren konstellation
deswegen meine damen
müssen wir auch weiterhin
freiheit und verantwortung koppeln aber
es gibt ja auch diejenigen die sagen
quasi wie montes kühl wenn es nicht
nötig ist ein gesetz zu machen ist es
nötig kein gesetz zu machen das wäre
aber an dieser stelle auch der falsche
weg gar keine maßnahmen gar keine
schutzkonzepte keine möglichkeit für die
länder ist hinzugekommen bei einem
hotspot regelungen zu treffen das wäre
auch der falsche weg die kollege wenn
das wäre kollege quelle gestatten sie
eine frage oder bemerkungen des kollegen
müller das würde mir manches kühne zu
ende bringen und das ging leider nicht
nein danke
diese idee
dieses gesetz
so zu auszugestalten dass wir auf der
einen seite schutz bei hotspots haben
und auf der anderen seite
dafür sorgen dass die menschen in den
alltag zurückfinden dass die menschen
ihre verantwortung umsetzen und ihrer
verantwortung gerecht werden können das
ist es was wir politisch einfordern
müssen denn meine damen und herren die
menschen in deutschland sind ja keine
kleinen kinder wir verbieten niemanden
masken zu tragen wir ermöglichen den
menschen ihre eigene verantwortung
selbst die hand nehmen und das spur kern
auch eine liberale idee und das ist es
doch meine damen und herren was wir in
den nächsten wochen und monaten im
nächsten halben jahr sehen werden das
heißt aber nicht dass wir nicht vor
neuen
varianten vor neuen entwicklungen in der
pandemie geschützt werden das heißt auch
nicht dass wir nicht lernfähig werden
denn natürlich können wir weiterhin
lernen natürlich werden wir auch zum
herbst wenn es notwendig ist mehr
beschließen können wir können auch über
den sommer mehr schießen denn politik
ist handlungsfähig politik beschließt
nicht etwas das in stein gemeißelt ist
sondern politik reagiert und kluge
pandemie politik reagiert und das ist es
was wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf machen
meine damen und herren
sie sehen auf jeden pflicht anders meine
damen und herren
der zeitpunkt jetzt ist völlig richtig
in diese richtung weiter zu gehen wir
sehen im europäischen vergleich dass wir
mit diesem gesetz zumindest nicht mehr
alleine dasteht wir sehen dass wir mit
diesen änderungen einen gemeinsamen weg
aus der pandemie gehen können
und natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
menschen weiterhin
verantwortungsbewusst mit der pandemie
natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
menschen sich impfen lassen natürlich
wissen wir dass auch weitere
entwicklungen in der pandemie nach dem
19 nicht zu ende sind und wir wissen
trotzdem dass es viele menschen in und
die allermeisten menschen in deutschland
gibt die verantwortungsbewusst mit ihrer
freiheit umgehen und das ist es was wir
mit diesem gesetz schaffen deswegen
vielen dank für die debatte vielen dank
für dieses gesetz und auf ein gutes
weiteres
die
betreiber dieses gesetzes quasi alle
maßnahmen können seien ab sonntag
wegfallen nur im begrenzten bereich gilt
dann noch die masten vielleicht heute
gab es 226 tote und die menschen die am
wochenende erkranken werden oder montag
kommender woche die ihm werden dann
teilweise in
den vier tagen drei wochen oder später
in dieser statistik erscheinen und so
grausam es ist aber so harmlos wie das
hier immer dargestellt wird ist die
omikron ikon variante bei weitem auch
nicht so seine fesche jetzt für die
präsidentin sie erfährt die kolleginnen
und kollegen herr minister die
bundesregierung möchte gerne die
fortschritts koalition seien aber was
bitte ist daran fortschrittlich dauernd
gesetze im schweinsgalopp durch das
parlament zu treiben die dann auch noch
handwerklich und inhaltlich schlecht
sind
dieses verfahren
beim infektionsschutz das haben wir
jetzt seit zwei jahren und die ampel die
top tatsächlich auch noch die groko nur
den pflege bonus den haben sie nicht
innerhalb einer woche hinbekommen an dem
d ernst seit monaten herum das ist
peinlich meine damen und herren
omikron verursacht zum glück weniger
schwere verläufe und ja die
ausgangssituation ist eine andere als
vorteil aber bei einem höchststand an
infektionen und bei täglichen longo bit
und todesfällen lockert man doch nicht
von 100 auf nahezu null
zu gunsten der freedom day partei
genannt fdp geben bundesregierung und
gesundheitsminister der ansonsten der
ewige mahner in der pandemie gewesen ist
hier eine politische bankrotterklärung
ab
ihre regionale hotspot regelungen sie
schafft einen flickenteppich an
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen sie lassen
damit die bundesländer im regen stehen
und sie fördern auch noch den föderalen
über bildungs und
unterbietungswettbewerb das ist wirklich
absurd meine damen und herren
und apropos absurd sie schaffen die
masken pflicht als basisschutz ab obwohl
masken nachweislich vor infektionen
schützen diskutieren aber gleichzeitig
über die einführung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht diese impfpflicht ist aber
wesentlich freiheitseinschränkende als
sich die pflicht sich für eine halbe
stunde im bus oder im bahn oder im
supermarkt maske um mund und nase zu
binden
und dann entschuldigung dieses blöde
argument von der fdp der mann dürfe ja
weiterhin die maske tragen es geht aber
nicht nur um eigenen schutz sondern es
geht um fremdschutz und das offenbar zu
deutlich ihr krudes verständnis von
freiheit
solidarität und rücksicht
sie wollten gruppen die sie angeblich
schützen wollen sie leben nämlich nicht
nur im heim die reden mitten in unserer
gesellschaft
pflegende angehörige eltern von kindern
mit vorgang bei vorerkrankungen die
kohlen offensichtlich in ihren
paralleluniversum gar nicht vor es ist
beschämend und
um es auf allen ebenen absurd zu machen
wird der infektionsschutz am
arbeitsplatz auch noch runter gefahren
wenn tests masken und homeoffice der
beliebigkeit der arbeitgeber unterliegen
ist die gesundheit der beschäftigten
gefährdet und es ist völlig inakzeptabel
nach zwei jahren pandemie ist doch
wirklich nicht zu viel verlangt einen
plan vorzulegen der uns durch diese und
künftige pandemien bringt die linke
erzielt so einen antrag eingebracht und
wir brauchen klare wenn dann regelungen
die bei vergleichbaren
infektionsgeschehen auch vergleichbare
maßnahmen gewährleisten kostenfreie test
auch pcr test und eine ausweitung der
impfkampagne da ist nach wie vor luft
nach oben und
und einen rechtsanspruch auf
infektionsschutz am arbeitsplatz und auf
home office
meine damen und herren die große
mehrheit in diesem land hätte ich jetzt
seit zwei jahren besonnen und
solidarisch an die regeln aber durch
intransparenz hauruckverfahren falsche
versprechungen zum beispiel auf ein ende
der pandemie geht mit jeder neuen welle
mehr vertrauen in politik und staat
verloren ihr gesetz trägt weiter dazu
bei und deswegen lehnen wir es unteren
ab vielen dank
susanne stellungsspiel
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken hat
kritisiert für den gehweg fliege bonus
brauche die ampel monate und so ein
gesetz hier wird direkt vom zaun
gebrochen die fdp verfolge einen
merkwürdigen freiheitsbegriff wenn sie
immer wieder alle rentiere man könne ja
weiter die maske tragen es gehe auch in
den brandschutz und vereinigungen diesen
freiheit so versteht es die fdp sei
seine freiheit von solidarität und
rücksicht diese länder die spd
kolleginnen und kollegen die zahlen der
letzten tage die uns immer wieder
erreichen machen glaube ich eins
deutlich dass wir weiter sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit dieser aktuellen
situation und den pandemie geschehen
umgehen müssen und das vollkommen
richtig auch aufgrund der aktuellen lage
was karl lauterbach gerade auch aus
geführt hat wir werden mit diesem gesetz
sicherlich keinen freedom day in diesem
land haben und das ist auch nicht etwas
was die ampel letztendlich mit diesem
gesetz verfolgt sondern es ein weiterer
verantwortungsvoller umgang mit der
aktuellen situation denn ich will es
noch einmal deutlich machen die regelung
in 28 a und 28 b des gelten
infektionsschutzgesetzes die würde wenn
wir keine fortgesetzte regelung finden
würden die wir heute auf den weg bringen
auslaufen und das würde bedeuten wenn
wir nichts tun würde es künftig gar
keine maßnahmen wie test oder masken
pflicht mehr geben können und das vor
dem hintergrund der aktuellen zahl
kurzum die rechtsgrundlagen für die
länder würden wenn wir heute nicht
dieses gesetz auf den weg bringen
ersatzlos wegfallen und das kann aus
unserer sicht nicht sein und darum ist
es richtig diesen vertretbaren
kompromiss heute auch auf den weg zu
bringen
und das will ich sagen es ist wichtig
diesen praktikablen kompromiss den wir
als ampel koalition verhandelt haben auf
den weg zu bringen die situation ist
anders als infektionsschutzgesetz
änderungen die wir in den vergangenen
jahren gehabt haben da wir eine hohe
zahl an impfungen letztendlich auch
haben die nachweislich vor einem
schweren verlauf auch schützen oder um
will ich danke sagen an
bundesgesundheitsminister lauter walzern
bundesjustizminister buschmann die
gemeinsam mit uns satz koalitionen
diesen kompromiss auf den weg gebracht
haben und herr sorge sie wussten dass
vielleicht nicht beide haben dem
zugestimmt nur man darf auch der
regierungsbank nicht klatschen darum
waren sie vielleicht in den letzten
jahren dirigiert das in spanien
herausgegeben hat aber das ist
eigentlich konsens im bundestag aber
vielleicht wirst du dir das an der
stelle ich glaube der kompromisse
vertretbar ergibt eine perspektive auch
im rahmen einer verantwortungsvollen
öffnungs perspektive schritte die auch
vereinbart worden sind aber wir müssen
uns glaube ich sehr deutlich bewusst
machen gerade für die situation des
kommenden herbst und winter das müssen
wir vorsorgen wir wollen dass diese
pandemie beherrschbar wird und vor dem
hintergrund ist es wichtig vorsorge zu
treffen letztendlich mit einer
allgemeinen pflicht die wir anfang april
in zweiter dritter lesung auf den weg
bringen wollen es ist ein eingewiesen
gestatten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
des kollegen so ja selbstverständlich
vielen dank herr kollege wiese dass die
zwischenfrage zulassen dass sie nicht
direkt angesprochen haben soll will ich
sie ganz kurz fragen finden sie das
parlamentarische verfahren normal und
als ein zeichen guter zusammenarbeit
wenn noch vor der verabschiedung des
gesetzes 16 ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder sagen das
gesetz ist schlecht das geht so nicht
sie wissen es nicht wie sie es umsetzen
soll und finden sie es normal dass noch
vor der ersten lesung dieses gesetzes
die anhörung stattfinden muss weil es
zeitlich nicht anders ging obwohl man
seit monaten wusste dass hier neue
regelung auf den weg gebracht werden
müssen
sehr geehrter kollege sorge haben sie
vielen dank für die zwischenphase
studium
nicht so
und den letzten heißt das mikro ein
bisschen untergegangen und das verbände
sagen dass das völlig atypisch sei das
heißt sie bekommen den gesetzentwurf um
0 18 an dem sonntag zugesandt und sollen
bis 10 uhr am montagmorgen dazu stellung
in finden sie das alles normal im
parlamentarischen verfahren vielen dank
sehr geehrter pflege sorge haben sie
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage weil
mir dass die möglichkeit gibt und ich
sehe den früheren
gesundheitsministeriums sparen ja auch
hier heute bei der debatte sitzen ich
habe seit mai 2020 einige änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes mit verhandeln
dürfen auch in der großen koalition und
ich kann ihnen sagen dass dieses
verfahren sicherlich zeitlich sehr
anspruchsvoll gewesen ist dass es sich
aber wohltuend abhebt von dem was wir
unter der leitung von helge braun im
kanzleramt den teilen erlebt haben wir
haben teilweise sehr hektische
verhandlungen geführt werden teilweise
sind aus den
sachen an die bild -zeitung gummis
gesprochen worden und darum kann ich nur
sagen es gibt sich sehr wohltuend ab wie
die bundesregierung diese änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in der ampel
koalition angeht ansonsten würde ich
mich freuen wenn sie stehen bleiben
solange ich ihre frage auch beantwortet
ob das gebietet auch der respekt
untereinander bei kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist letztendlich ein kompromiss den
wir auf den weg bringen der die menschen
die bohne rebellengruppen ganz besonders
schützen möchte und in den blick nimmt
er ist aber auch ein kompromiss der auch
die verhältnismäßigkeit watt und darum
ist es richtig wohl mehr abele gruppen
besonders zu schützen es ist auch
richtig die massen pflicht gerade im
öpnv letztendlich auch weiter zu wald
und das ist auch richtig dass wir den
ländern die möglichkeit geben bei
vorliegen einer konkreten gefahr einer
sich dynamisch ausbreitenden
infektionsrate gehende schutzmaßnahmen
im rahmen einer hotspot regelung auf den
weg zu bringen und das heißt die länder
können letztendlich für kreise für
kreisfreie städte aber auch für das
gesamte bundesland diese hotspot
regelungen auf den weg bringen das halte
ich für richtig und ich sage es auch
sehr deutlich ich finde es richtig dass
die länder den weg über die landtage
gehen müssen die kolleginnen und
kollegen in den landtagen können dass
verantwortlich machen die werden das gut
machen das ist die demokratische
rückkopplung die wir herstellen
auch drauf
jetzt habe ich allerdings auch den einen
oder anderen hinweis ja gerade auch von
norman er sorge auch von ihrer rede
bezüglich der ministerpräsidenten ich
will auch mal einen blick in die
christdemokratische praxis in den
bundesländern letztendlich werfen wo
waren denn die verschärfungen aufgrund
einer steigenden infektionsgeschehen in
nordrhein westfalen von
ministerpräsident wies nach dem kölner
karneval wo hat die landesregierung denn
da die
notwendigkeiten gesehen voranzugehen und
wenn ich mir anschaue was derzeit in der
krone schutz verordnung des landes
nordrhein-westfalen geregelt ist und was
das land mit den öffnungszeiten
voranbringen will in nordrhein westfalen
dann ist das übrigens deckungsgleich mit
dem was wir in dem zukünftigen
infektionsschutzgesetz den ländern zur
verfügung stellt von daher scheint ihre
ministerpräsidenten an dem punkt doch
sehr zufrieden zu sein und von daher
verstehe ich den einen oder anderen
punkte an der stelle nicht will aber
auch deutlich machen
und da will ich mal einen blick nach
bayern werfen und entschuldigen sie herr
dobrindt das was ich jetzt ausführe ist
die gemütslage des bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten von gestern abend es
kann durchaus sein dass er seine meinung
bis heute morgen geändert hat
und das ist ein entscheid nach
bayern kraft ab kommenden montag die
masten pflicht für grundschüler in den
schulen ab die übergangsregelung die wir
den bundesländern gewähren würde die
möglichkeit geben dies noch bis zum
zweiten viertel auch zu machen dann kann
es letztendlich ja nicht so sein dass
wie markus söder das schildert hier
maßnahmen die er zur verfügung hätte für
ihn nicht ausreichend sind das heißt er
macht gar nicht gebrauch von
übergangsregelungen wie wir ihn im
infektionsschutzgesetz zur verfügung
stellt und das muss ich schon sagen das
was düsseldorf münchen da letztendlich
vor ort machen das ist in einer gewissen
weise unglaubwürdig und widerspricht dem
was sie heute an dem gesetz kritisiert
vielen dank ihr aufnehmen
diese verfügen dass gut die der
bundestag diskutiert um zweiter dritter
lesung die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
die nächste rednerin kommt von der cdu
leben ja die
sprecherin
und stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
der christen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen heute beraten
wir auch den antrag der cdu csu fraktion
zur verlängerung der korona bedingten
elterngeld regelungen und ich muss schon
sagen wir haben uns doch sehr gewundert
als im rahmen ihres entwurfs zum so
deckt bei all den verlängerungen der
korona bedingten sonderregeln niemand
aus ihrer koalition und auch nicht die
zuständige bundesfamilienministerin
spiegel an die verlängerung der korona
bedingten elterngeld regeln gedacht hat
aber wir hätten ja gern als opposition
und deswegen freue ich mich dass sie
unseren änderungsantrag vollständigen
übernommen haben aber eins werden man
kann
schöne in der schule beim schreiben das
selbstständige denken nicht einstellen
denn auch die besseren schüler machen
meinen fehler wie sie haben nämlich auch
den redaktionellen fehler der uns
unterlaufen ist in unserem
änderungsantrag in der begründung eins
zu eins übernommen
vielleicht besteht ja noch die
möglichkeit der korrektur schauen sie
mal nach wir haben verwiesen auf satz 3
in paragraf 2 absatz 1 gg
es müsste satz 4 sein und der fehler ist
ihnen unterlaufen vielleicht korrigieren
sie das aber aber
es geht um die sache es geht uns um die
vielen eltern die in den nächsten tagen
ein kind erwarten die in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen eltern geworden sind es
geht um die eltern die in den
vergangenen drei monaten pandemie
bedingt in kurzarbeit waren oder
arbeitslosengeld bezogen haben deren
kinder krank waren oder die die kinder
zu hause betreuen mussten weil die
einrichtungen kitas schule pandemie
pandemie bedingt geschlossen waren diese
eltern müssen zukünftig nicht mehr
fürchten weniger elterngeld zu bekommen
denn die monate in denen sie
kurzarbeitergeld arbeitslosengeld kinder
krank geld oder andere pandemie bedingte
sonderregelung erhalten haben die können
außer ausgeklammert werden es geht aber
auch um die eltern die aufgrund der
pandemie den partnerschafts bonus nicht
bekommen können weil einfach die zeiten
so waren wie sie sind auch diese eltern
müssen nun nicht mehr fürchten dass sie
keine elterngeld bekommen oder noch viel
schlimmer es zurückzahlen müssen für all
diese jungen eltern haben wir uns als
opposition stark gemacht und letztlich
auch die koalition überzeugt die
pandemie bedingten sondern fehlen werden
dem bundeselterngeld- und
elternzeitgesetz nicht nur verlängert
sondern rückwirkend ab ende dezember
22 gelten und das ist eine gute
nachricht für sein
[Applaus]
revier bringen
wenn man einen fehler macht und die wird
abgeschrieben das ist natürlich
der nächste
ist mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich
will mit großer ehrlichkeit diese rede
beginnen die debatte heute die
abstimmungen die anstehen nachher die
fallen mir persönlich äußerst schwer
weil ich bezweifle dass das vorliegende
infektionsschutzgesetz letztlich der
lage die wir haben angemessen ist wir
hätten uns auch andere auch
weitergehende regelungen vorstellen
können und dass es auch kein geheimnis
in diesem haus über steigenden
infektionszahlen immer mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen auch vielen
toten jeden tag die basis
schutzmaßnahmen so weit nach unten zu
fahren so rigoros nach unten zu fahren
dass es nicht die vorsorgen die politik
die wir gerne auch hier beschlossen
hätten zumindest die masken pflicht
zumindest die masken pflicht in
innenräumen hätte bestehen bleiben
müssen und lieber kollege köhler liebe
fdp wenn menschen mit vorerkrankungen
sich zu hause einschließen müssen weil
unsere gesellschaft weil wir zu
rücksichtslos dafür sind masken in
öffentlichen räumen zu tragen dann ist
das nicht mein verständnis von freiheit
heute hier zwischen zuzustimmen fällt
mir schwer und dennoch werbe ich dafür
weil die alternative keine regelungen zu
haben keine alternative ist und weil wir
viele andere regelungen heute hier haben
die wir mit beschließen es geht um die
eltern das wurde gerade gesagt dass es
richtig es geht aber auch um die vielen
sozialen einrichtungen die wir in
deutschland haben und die wir
selbstverständlich sichern müssen und
vor dem bankrott zu schützen müssen das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz ist
ein schutzschirm den ganz viele brauchen
und ganz viele sind so froh darüber dass
wir es schaffen dass heute hier zu
verabschieden und schon allein deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir weiter
gesetzliche regelungen haben
wir brauchen und wir brauchen so
dringend die wohlfahrtsverbände die
müttergenesungswerkes wir brauchen die
freien kita träger wir brauchen die
anbieter von sprachkursen
selbstverständlich wir brauchen
einrichtungen für menschen mit
behinderungen all das ist das was wir in
der gesellschaft gerade in einer solchen
pandemie brauchen und die menschen die
dort arbeiten die haben über ihrer
belastungsgrenze in den letzten monaten
gearbeitet die haben unterstützt die
haben die haben geholfen die haben
unterrichtet so wie es eben gerade noch
gegen und diese menschen die verdienen
respekt verdienen anerkennung die
verdienen aber vielmehr die verdienen
dass wir hier heute sicherstellen dass
sie gut finanziert und sicher
aufgestellt auch in dieser
krisensituation ihre arbeit machen
können
[Applaus]
und wohnt
und wo könnte das plastischer werden als
wenn wir uns die kinder und jugend reha
anschauen in dieser panieren das wissen
wir alle haben kinder und jugendliche so
unglaublich auch immer wieder ertragen
müssen sie haben immer wieder gelitten
und wenn wir diesen kindern und
jugendlichen eine zukunft geben wollen
dann müssen wir die soziale
infrastruktur sichern die diesen kindern
und jugendlichen hilft die dort hingehen
wo die probleme sind und die menschen
dann auch eine perspektive aus dieser
schwierigen lage heraus entwickeln kann
bei all diesen
bei all diesen institutionen bei all
diesen institutionen herrscht weiter
ausnahmezustand und dann kann man so oft
wie man will hier in diesem parlament
auch den normalzustand herbeireden es
wird dadurch nicht besser dort herrscht
ausnahmezustand
und so viele haben mit mir jetzt in den
wochen davor gesprochen und darum
gebeten dass wir diese gesetze
verlängern genau das tun wir ich habe
große sorgen dass das bedeutet dass das
was wir heute beschließen nicht
ausreicht und dennoch ist es wichtig
genau das zu tun was wir heute tun
dankeschön
v abgeordnete beiden wir würden hier
exakt 1 redezeit protokoll und managen
auch mit den fraktionen bei redezeit
überziehung das redezeiten entsprechend
abgezogen werden so wie wir das auch
seit mittwochmittag und im übrigen nicht
nur in dieser woche praktizieren das
präsidium brauchte dazu jetzt keine
unterstützung aus dem leben
hirst hat der abgeordnete stefan
brandner will die fdp
offensichtlich war dafür der hft
angemeldet worden dass der florida keys
zu lange gesprochen hat und frau hatte
darauf hingewiesen dass wird wie gehabt
gehandhabt der nächste redner aus der
fraktion erhält einfach weniger redet
seit inzwischen vier meiner mutter ehren
das infektionsschutzgesetz steht damit
auch die tagesordnungen schwieriges
thema wenn man den zensoren von youtube
und co entgehen möchte ich versuche
trotzdem es ist erst ein paar stunden
her dass herr lauterbach einer der
größten im plan ist in diesem lande hier
von vorne ein wahres horrorszenario an
die wand gemalt hat zwar im rahmen der
impfzwang debatte am gestrigen tag hat
die debatte ja verfolgt er lauter was
sie haben eine knappe minute gebraucht
und in dieser knappen minute in am
anfang ihrer rede war ein halbes dutzend
dann tische
schreckensszenarien die alle über uns
hereinbrechen werden ich sage ihnen
voraus kein einziges dieser
schreckensszenarien wird ein treffen mir
leid aber sie sind ein lügner von hier
vorne gewesen immer schon und sie werden
es auch bleiben und ich denke daran an
ihrer aussage im herbst 20 21 mit
krokodilstränen haben sie prognostiziert
bis märz 2022 seien in deutschland alle
geimpft genesen oder leider gestorben
das lebende beispiel der roboter bach
steht hier vor ihnen weder geimpft noch
gelesen und auch noch nicht gestorben
das mag jetzt daran liegen dass noch
nicht ende märz ist sie haben sich ja
was den märz an geht nicht festgelegt
das mag vielleicht daran liegen dass die
großen unsinn erzählt haben ich vermute
mal letzteres und erwarte von ihnen der
lauterbach dass sie sich bei den vielen
millionen menschen sie mit dieser
aussage in angst und panik versetzt
haben zumindest entschuldigen es sind
nicht millionen menschen gestorben die
nicht geimpften da macht es die sache
auch nicht besser dass der herr sparen
dann habe ich irgendwo wir sehen ihn
dabei sekundiert hat der herr sparen
übrigens der offenbar mit
gesundheitspolitik nichts mehr am hut
hat er macht jetzt in wirtschaft und
energie wahrscheinlich gibt es die
bessere lobby verträge ersparen also ein
verlust für die gesundheits
für die gesundheitspolitik ist das nicht
wenn ich mir diesen impfen lassen muss
ja lauterbach von hier vorne anschaue
dann bin ich der überzeugung kommen wir
brauchen eigentlich eher ein injektions
schutzgesetz als sein
infektionsschutzgesetz wenn sie weiter
hier als bundesminister arbeiten wollen
also wir arbeiten daran ein
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg zu
bringen erläutert wir reden heute auch
über die ausnahme vorschriften im
bereich der geschäftsordnung der
parlamentarische ausnahmezustand soll ja
fortgesetzt werden obwohl die pandemie
weitestgehend vorbei ist etwa 126 a der
geschäftsordnung soll erstmal bis juli
verlängert werden sie haben sich bequem
eingerichtet was die arbeit in den
ausschüssen angeht das kann man
inzwischen zu hause vom sofa aus machen
man kann sich zuschalten lassen man
kriegt trotzdem die trotzdem die
anwesenheit bescheinigt wir sagen weg
damit freiheitstag nicht nur in
deutschland freiheitstag auch im
deutschen bundestag wir brauchen im
deutschen bundestag genauso wenig wie in
der gesamten republik eine ausnahme
vorschriften mehr zurück zur normalität
das funktioniert nur mit der
freiheitspartei
nur mit der alternative für deutschland
nur mit der fraktion der alternative für
deutschland in diesem bundestag gesagt
lehnen die verlängerung der ausnahme
vorstellung des 226 der geschäftsordnung
ab und der lauterbacher erwarte jetzt
von ihnen die entschuldigung
bessergegangen
zur zart besaitet oder er flüchtete
weiter verdienen die entschuldigung die
konzerte von daraus machen
dann bin ich zufrieden danke schön
hier der verbrannten schon viereinhalb
jahren deutschen hohenhausen bundestag
hat als sie von den abläufen recht wenig
ahnung denn ein minister davon seinem
stehen
dazwischen
intervention und ich nehme an dass
karate was ich jetzt dazu melden wird
persönliche erklärung wird jetzt
angemeldet und im übrigen dass der herr
sparen jetzt die wirtschaft macht ist
auch völlig normal nämlich
ausgeschiedene bundesminister widmen
sich grundsätzlich einem anderen thema
das ist zwar nur uns so festgeschrieben
aber seit 70 jahren so üblich hier im
hohen hause
[Musik]
also eine kurzintervention als minister
geht nicht von der minister bank sondern
über als abgeordneter aus töchtern war
für uns alle für die demokratischen
sprechen möchte ich sagen wir möchten
wir wollen uns hier nicht als lügner
diffamieren lassen das ist das nicht
wir müssen uns nicht als lügner
diffamiert wird streit in der sache
jeder zeit aber hier haben
unterschiedliche meinungen aber hier
sprechen was den demokratischen parteien
an hier sprechen keine lügner
dafür schon von vielen leuten in der tat
so war die süchte aufgefallen nicht nur
das bekannte
[Applaus]
karl lauterbach gesagt
ein lügner ist in meinen augen jemand
der mindestens einmal die unwahrheit
sagte vor die wahrheit kennt ja was sie
erzählen uns seit zwei jahren am
laufenden band die unwahrheit obwohl sie
die wahrheit wahrscheinlich kennen also
seien sie froh dass ich sie lediglich
als lügner bezeichnet habe und nicht
noch andere wörter gewählt habe vielen
dank
dann haben wir das im protokoll
entsprechend format
und wir fahren in der debatte fort das
wort hat die kollegin christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das was der
herr brandner eben gemacht hat ist
unanständig meine damen und herren das
gehört sich nicht in den deutschen
bundestag es ist unglaublich was sie
sich hier leisten
und in der ersten rede der ard wurde
behauptet es sei zu keiner zeit zu einer
überlastung der krankenhäuser gekommen
auch das ist eine unwahrheit was sie
hier behaupten wir haben noch vor kurzem
die patienten aus einzelnen
krankenhäuser ausgeflogen in andere
krankenhäuser weise überlastet waren
insofern erzählen sie auch die
unwahrheit hier und nehmen sie sich
einfach anständig und kollegial und da
wären wir schon zufrieden mehr erwarten
wir von ihnen gar nicht so liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wiederhole
es immer wieder gebetsmühlenartig
selbstverständlich ist die pandemie noch
nicht vorbei aber die situation ist eine
andere als wir sie noch vor zwei jahren
hatten wir sind weit entfernt vor den
von den zuständen die wir hatten und
deswegen müssen wir eben auch andere
maßnahmen ergreifen als wir sie vor zwei
jahren hatten wir müssen lernen mit dem
virus zu leben denn wir werden das virus
so schnell nicht los meine damen und
herren und deswegen sind die geplanten
vorliegenden änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz ein wichtiger
schritt in richtung normalität aber bei
gleichzeitiger handlungsfähigkeit und
das ist doch das wichtige an der ganzen
sache
das oberste ziel der pandemie bekämpfung
war und ist es immer eine überlastung
des gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und
vor allem unsere wollen haben gruppen zu
schützen und genau das setzen wir mit
diesem gesetz um wir müssen angemessen
und zielgerichtet agieren meine damen
und herren und wir schaffen ja auch
nicht alle maßnahmen ab so wie das hier
manchmal behauptet wird in bestimmten
bereichen wie in krankenhäusern alten-
und pflegeeinrichtungen einrichtungen
für menschen mit behinderung da wird
weiterhin mit tests und masken
gearbeitet meine damen und herren und an
einzelnen stellen haben wir auch
nachgeschärft beispielsweise das auch in
arztpraxen masken getragen werden müssen
aber völlig anderes sieht es im bereich
der schulen und kindertagesstätten aus
es macht doch ein unterschied ob sich
höhere infizieren oder
risikopatienten und diesen unterschied
müssen wir auch bei den maßnahmen
ableiten denn die kinder haben
glücklicherweise einen wesentlich
milderen verlauf bei der omicron
variante und wir wissen doch wollen wir
unsere branchen berg in dainbach ich
habe die uhr angehalten gestalten sie
eine frage oder bemerkungen der kollegin
lindholz welche fraktionen von cdu/csu
entschuldigung ja gerne
ja erst mal liebe frau aschenbrenner
vielen dank für die zulassung der
zwischen frage
ich habe ihren ausführungen schon
diese woche beim letzten mal zugehört
und auch heute wieder und ich würde
ihnen gerne eine einen fall schildern
und fragen was wir diesen personen
antworten sollen sie sagen ja immer sie
schaffen die masken pflicht nicht ganz
ab sie lassen sie im kranken
krankenhäusern weiter zu sie lassen sie
im öffentlichen personennahverkehr
weiter bestehen sie lassen sie aber zb
nicht weiter bestehen im bereich des
öffentlichen lebens im supermarkt und
das lassen sie auch nicht über den april
hinaus bestehen und wir haben eine
instanz die heute bei aktuell
1600 irgendetwas liegt also nahe 1700
wir haben 2 180 todesfälle was sagen sie
einer krebskranken oder anders
schwerkranken jungen frau alten frau ein
mann also einer person die alles umgehen
kann die nicht in der gaststätte gehen
muss die vielleicht auch sich nicht
privat großtreffen muss die aber
zumindest zum einkaufen gehen muss und
beim einkaufen diese frau versucht alles
dieser man diese person um sich nicht zu
infizieren weil er sich mitten in einer
krebstherapie befindet was sagen sie
dieser person die möchte in zukunft in
den supermarkt gehen nach wie vor und
sie möchte in zukunft geschützt werden
aber sie ist in zukunft nicht mehr
geschützt sie selber kann ihre maske
aufziehen das stimmt aber ihr gegenüber
ihr gegenüber muss die maske im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr noch
aufziehen aber nicht im supermarkt was
sagen sie einer solchen person der wir
bei den jetzigen inzidenz und
todeszahlen die masken pflicht mit der
masken pflicht den schutz wegnehmen und
die kollegen von der fdp ich höre in
zwischenruf jedesmal und deswegen für
ich länger aus ja sie kann die maske
freiwillig aufsetzen aber ihr gegenüber
nicht und ein wirksamer schutz liebe
frau aschenberg dugnus liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der fdp erfordert ist
dass beide personen eine maske aufziehen
ich frage sie jetzt wie sie bei diesen
ins tänzen das gegenüber diesen wohl der
arabien personen vertreten können
sehr geehrte frau kollegin genau das
also entschuldigung ministrant jetzt
kollegen lindholz das mikrofon ist aus
die frage ist verstanden und jetzt hat
die kollegin aschenberg dugnus das wort
für die beantwortung vielen dank für
ihre frage die wir ja häufiger von ihnen
hören und der von ihnen geschuldet
geschilderte fall würde ich sagen bitte
setzen sie die maske auf den eine ft2
maske hat nachweisbar einen 34 fachen
schutz und ist völlig ausreichend um
sich im leben bewegen zu können und das
können sie diese dieser dame oder diesem
heraus sagen und dann geben sie immer
von den instanzen aus sie müssen doch
konstatieren dass wir jetzt ein
unterschied haben wir haben wahnsinnig
hohe fallzahlen aber auch heute wieder
wenn sie auf den export gehen sehen sie
das auch wieder die intensivpatienten
die zahl abgenommen hat das heißt mal
riesigen instanzen haben wir weniger
fälle auf den intensivstationen
das heißt das virus ist milder im
verlauf und erzählen sie den leuten doch
mal was positives dass sie sich mit
masken schützen können und dass wir zum
beispiel wenn sie auf den lkw bericht
gehen auch wesentlich weniger todesfälle
haben als noch in der vierten welle als
wir jetzt fast 3000 todesfälle pro woche
hatten da sind wir noch weit von
entfernt sagen sie das doch mal den
leuten dass sie auch sagen können sie
können sich schützen aber sie können
auch am leben teilnehmen als solche
horrorszenarien über aufzuspielen
ihr müsst die perspektiven für die
menschen geben wir müssen noch sagen es
geht weiter ihr könnt wieder etwas tun
und wenn sie jetzt vom einkaufen reden
ich weiß sie wollen alles staatlich
vorschreiben in meinem heimatort strande
war es schon längst üblich da wo viele
ältere sind da gibt es da kann man zb
vor ort auch extra einkaufszeiten machen
dann geht man als als älterer mensch mit
maske dahin und hat speziell einkaufs
sein es gibt so viele möglichkeiten zu
agieren aber wir müssen doch auch sehen
dass in bestimmten bereichen und dazu
komme ich noch zum beispiel bei den
kindern dass es doch gerade fahrlässig
ist da mit einer massen pflicht zu
arbeiten das geht doch nicht und wir
können doch jetzt nicht die
bildungschancen die sozialen chancen
unserer kinder aufrechnen gegen die
mühlen gruppen mit unserem gesetz
schützen wir die wohlhabenden gruppen
aber bieten unseren kindern und
jugendlichen auch die möglichkeit
bildung zu erlangen soziales leben zu
erlangen und das ist doch genau das was
wir wollen frau kollegin
und deswegen aus meinem leben
ausgeführten können sie hören dass sie
bleibt dabei eine frage die rede
kollegin lindholz ich habe heute zu
beginn unserer debatte die geltenden
regeln die wir seit mittwoch auch
durchhalten läutet gelassen jeder eine
frage und antwort zu nach wie vor ist
die zeit nicht limitiert das ist denke
ich jetzt auch
beantwortet und jetzt bitte ich hier in
der debatte vor zuschauen wie die wurde
die studentin ich fahre ford aus dem
eben gesagten können sie hören oder
können sie heraus hören wie wichtig uns
die bildungschancen und unsere kinder
sind in dem wir sie eben nicht mehr dazu
zwingen maske zu tragen und damit sind
wir auch mit vielen kinderpsychologen
einer meinung viele kinderärzte fordern
dass auch das ist also nicht nur die fdp
hat uns überhaupt der kollege wiese hat
es ja geschildert herr söder schafft er
jetzt die masken pflicht auch ab in den
augen grundschulen also so schlecht kann
unser gesetz doch gar nicht sein auf der
einen seite fordern sie allgemeine
masken pflicht aber wenn es dann zum
schwur kommt sie doch anders wie zum
beispiel herr söder also bei ihnen
stimmt auch in der argumentation ganz
vieles nicht weil da und jetzt nochmal
zur mikro sie hat nur einmal andere
folgen als die delta variante und
deswegen müssen wir eben auch um andere
maßnahmen ergreifen und ich möchte
abschließend noch mal betonen und das
ist das positive wir sind doch den virus
nicht hilflos ausgesetzt wir haben gut
funktionierende impfungen deswegen
lassen sie sich impfen und lassen sie
sich gestern wir haben medikamente aber
was ich sagen muss wir laufen leider
immer der entwicklung hinterher und
deswegen werden die als cooler koalition
jetzt auf ein frühwarnsystem auf den weg
bringen das ist uns als fdp ganz
besonders wichtig mit mit einem abwasser
monitoring- oder zb mit repräsentativen
studien damit wir genau wissen was im
herbst winter auf uns zukommt und warum
dann mit diesem gesetz zielgerichtet zu
agieren das sind wir der bevölkerung
schuldig zielgerichtet und nicht einfach
so querbeet dankeschön für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
weil das team optimal der sitzung war
wirklich gern noch mal aus die institute
heute
3700 6,3 das ist die höchste in stent de
in deutschland gemessen wurde
297.000
845 personen sind heute aktueller krankt
und 226 tote sind in den letzten 24
stunden
matthias von der spd einer der neuen
abgeordneten heute mit seiner ersten
rede vor dem hohen hause
[Applaus]
als erstes möchte ich erstmal
genesungswünsche ausrichten an unseren
kollegen manuel cover er ist leider
alkohol erkrankt er hätte heute biete
rede gehalten
wir beraten heute neben einer änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz
dessen verlängerung und weitere
regelungen dieses leistet und bereits
seit beginn der pandemie wertvolle
dienste indem es den einsatz von
sozialen dienstleistern zur
krisenbewältigung sichert und die
wirtschaftliche leistungsfähigkeit
aufrecht erhält die sozialen
dienstleister hierzu zählen
beispielsweise die werkstätten von
menschen mit behinderung reha und
versorgungseinrichtungen sowie die
anbieter von sprachkursen leisten bei
der gesellschaftlichen krisen bewältigen
unverzichtbare arbeit und stellen daher
eine wichtige säule der pandemie
bekämpfung da die
den bestand oder sozialen infrastruktur
maßgeblich hat leider ist die pandemie
immer noch nicht überwunden so dass auch
die sozialen dienstleister corona
bedingt wirtschaftliche belastungen
unterliegen und daher weiterhin auf
finanzielle unterstützung angewiesen
sind die situationen da sind der
sozialen dienstleister stark von
weiteren infektionsschutz maßnahmen
abhängig und somit mit ungewissheit und
großer unsicherheit verbunden mit dem
sieg steht uns ein wichtiges effektives
instrument zur verfügung das dazu
geeignet ist die unsicherheiten
aufzufangen und damit die wichtig ein
wichtiges politisches signal zu setzen
dass in einer unsicheren zeit
beständigkeit und sicherheit vermittelt
auch wenn damit zu rechnen ist dass die
infektionszahlen während der
sommermonate wieder rückläufig sein
werden ist es wichtig dass wir gerade
auch im hinblick auf unsicherheiten bzw
möglicherweise neu auftauchende
virusvarianten oder bevorstehende
urlaubssaison mit umsicht und
vorausschauend handeln und
handlungsfähig bleiben dabei ist jedoch
zu betonen dass die verlängerung des 6
keine finanziellen belastungen ausgeben
sofern keine weiteren maßnahmen nach
infektionsschutzgesetz
ergriffen werden müssen die verlängerung
des rolex erhalten wir nicht nur eine
wichtige rechtsgrundlage aufrecht die es
den leistungsträgern weiterhin
ermöglicht zahlungen an den sozialen
dienstleistern zu leisten sondern
sichern zugleich auch eine reihe von
maßnahmen die sich in vergangenheit
bewährt gemacht haben die zu
beschließenden maßnahmen enden
spätestens am 23 september 2022 um zu
erreichen dass das ende september tat
sich eine weitere maßnahme nicht
notwendig sind ist unser wichtiges
mittel wie corona schutzimpfung unser
und stehen und deutschland nicht nur
sicherer sondern auch wirksamer
impfstoff zur verfügung
[Applaus]
nach wie vor sind die impfquoten nicht
hoch genug gerade deshalb ist es auch
weiterhin besonders wichtig denn
augenmerk auf betriebliche
infektionsschutz maßnahmen zu legen um
sichere arbeitsbedingungen zu
gewährleisten für die kollegen und
kolleginnen
hierzu zählen vor allen dingen auch die
haarige testungen sowie das angebot von
impfungen gerade diese maßnahmen haben
sich in ferner hat vergangenheit mit
großem nutzen bewertet mit der
verlängerung des wird darüber hinaus
dafür sorge getragen dass pandemie
bedingte soziale risiken abgefedert
werden dass die erhöhung der kinder
krankentage zum beispiel von 10 auf 30
tagen die lebensqualität von
erwerbstätigen eltern entspricht haben
wir gesehen daran dass er die
krankenkassen in 2021 mehr als doppelt
so viele anträge verzeichneten wie noch
in 2020 auch in den kommenden monaten
muss damit gerechnet werden dass kinder
sich auch wenn sie nicht selbst erkrankt
sind in isolation oder quarantäne
begeben müssen die fortschreibung der
erhöhung der kinder krankentage ist
folglich unerlässlich damit kinder damit
eltern ihre kinder pflegen und betreuen
können
die erhöhung der kinder krankentage war
zwar aus anlass der pandemie eingeführt
allerdings habe ich auch als vater einer
mittlerweile fünf jahre alten tochter
die erfahrung gemacht dass die
bisherigen rand zahl der kinder
krankentage vor allen dingen während der
kita eingewöhnungszeit nicht ausreichte
auch unabhängig von der pandemie lage
wäre einer höhe dieser wünschenswert
nicht nur im hinblick auf die korona
diese gilt dass wir dafür sorge tragen
müssen dass alle menschen die darauf
angewiesen sind ausreichende
unterstützung erhalten und rückhalt
durch den sozialstaat erfahren die in
vielen jahrzehnten gewachsene soziale
infrastruktur ist systemrelevant und
muss daher gerade jetzt in zeiten der
krise besonders unterstützt werden im
verlauf der pandemie konnten durch die
finanzielle unterstützung nachdem
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetz
zahlreiche sozialen dienstleister wie
zum beispiel reha kliniken oder
vorsorgeeinrichtungen vor der schließung
bewahrt werden dieser status gilt es zu
erhalten die verlängerung des
sozialdienstes ansatz ist daher
unverzichtbar zum schluss meiner rede
bleibt ist mir zu bitten um zustimmung
zu dieser vorlage
hätten sie zwar mit besonders viel
applaus seine erste reden hier für die
spd im wohnhaus der bundestag debattiert
über die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
zweiter und dritter lesung nachher wird
es dazu eine abstimmung geben und heute
mittag muss dann der bundesrat noch
zustimmen
ich sehe hier
kollegen
von der fdp bin ich in unserem
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder sehr dankbar dass er die masken
pflicht in den grundschulen abschafft
wir lassen die kinder dort in der schule
nicht alleine
denn mit
regelmäßigen tests und auch mit
lüftungsanlagen die durchaus regelmäßig
in den schulen vorhanden sind schaffen
wir eine nötigen schutz und gleichzeitig
gehen wir auf die bedürfnisse der kinder
ein denn es ist klar so dass wenn der
spracherwerb und der ist in der
grundschule besonders im fokus getätigt
werden muss es entscheidend demgegenüber
ins gesicht schauen zu können auf die
mundbewegungen schauen zu können und
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir in
bayern diesen schritt abgebogen gegangen
sind nichtsdestotrotz sind sie natürlich
sehr inkonsequent in ihrer argumentation
denn wenn auf der einen seite mit
bundesminister lauterbach eben seine
gesetzliche regelung darstellt das eben
hotspots auch ganze bundesländer
betrifft und gleichzeitig sie als fdp
davon sprechen dass nur einzelne
landkreise betroffen sein könnten dann
passt das nicht zusammen sie sind nicht
eins in der ampelkoalition und das
lassen wir ihnen auch nicht gehen und
nicht durchgehen lassen ihnen dass auch
die ministerpräsidenten der länder und
das sind also mit verlaub nicht nur
unionsgeführte länder dabei sondern
natürlich auch die lern des
ministerpräsidenten von spd und mit
natürlich beteiligung auch der fdp
deswegen es passt in ihrem gesetz ganz
offensichtlich etwas nicht zusammen und
auch in den massnahmen passend tassen
dinge nicht zusammen denn sie geben auf
der einen seite weiterhin warnungen aus
und gleichzeitig schaffen sie
beispielsweise die unterstützungen die
versorgungs aufschläge
ausgleichszahlungen für krankenhäusern
für arztpraxen ab auch damit lassen sie
gerade krankenhäusern im ländlichen raum
arztpraxen im regen stehen und es geht
in einer reihe damit und deswegen haben
wir als union auch einen änderungsantrag
eingebracht den sie wahrscheinlich nicht
gelesen haben aber ich werde es sehr
dafür dass zu tun nämlich dass wir eben
auch bonuszahlungen für die fordern die
eben die notaufnahmen leer gehalten
haben und dass der pflege bonus das
wurde kritisiert von unserem
gesundheitsminister holetschek aber auch
vom kollegen klar dass er immer noch
nicht auf den weg gebracht wurde das ist
ein skandal dass ich arbeitsverweigerung
lassen und das bei diesem
regel bonus hier jetzt angedacht ist
dass die medizinischen fachangestellten
zahnmedizinischen fachangestellten und
auch mitarbeiter im rettungswesen keine
berücksichtigung finden auch das finde
ich empörend denn auch sie waren es die
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen haben dass
die impfkampagne funktioniert hat dass
die leute schnell von a nach b gekommen
sind dass die leute in der quarantäne
nicht einfach ab wenn ab administriert
wurden sondern dass sie ansprechpartner
hatten und deswegen gehört es sich
meiner meinung nach dass wir diesen
bonus einführen nicht nur für die pflege
auch für die mitarbeiter im
rettungswesen auch für die medizinischen
fachangestellten und deswegen vor der
sie ganz konkret aus gehen sie mit uns
einen schritt weiter fortschritts
koalition wir wollen zukunft gestalten
wir wollen einen bund länder gipfel für
die reform der ausbildung der
medizinischen fachangestellten das
betrifft rund 500.000 vor allem frauen
in unserem land da müssen wir handeln da
müssen wir zukunft gestalten und
deswegen lesen sie den antrag der
unionsfraktionen und schaffen sie mit
uns gemeinsam einen bonus der über den
pflege bonus hinausgeht danke
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun der kollege helge limburg das
wort
berlino küsste rechtspolitischen
sprecher und wir müssten
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen hugh frau
kollegin seiner 1 habe ich nicht
verstanden ihrer vorbemerkung den
verständlichen wunsch dass die massen
pflichten grundschulen feld zu begrüßen
und anschließend das gesetz was genau
diesen wunsch erst ermöglicht abzulehnen
das passt für mich nicht zu sammeln
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen viele menschen möchten endlich
ohne impfnachweis und ohne maske
einkaufen ohne maske im theater oder
kino sitzen oder ford zu einer hat's
gesagt ohne maske in der schule sitzen
und dieser wunsch ist verständlich
der muss auch nicht gerechtfertigt oder
begründet werden ein freier
demokratischer rechtsstaat darauf hat
der köhler zu recht hingewiesen muss
jede grundrecht einschränkung begründen
und nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger ein
bisschen begründen warum sie keinen
haftbefehl aber
genauso verständlich und legitim ist
eben auch der wunsch von menschen und
zwar auch von menschen mit
vorerkrankungen von wohlhabenden gruppen
und anderen am sozialen leben teilhaben
zu können zum beispiel im supermarkt
oder in anderen geschäften einkaufen zu
können ohne die sorge haben zu müssen
sich dabei mit dem corona lehre zu
infizieren
auch die können sich auch pflichten des
staates nämlich auch schutzpflichten
berufen natürlich kann es einen
komplettschutz nicht geben aber ich kann
schon die leute verstehen die sagen naja
müsst ihr angesichts dieser doch sehr
hohen infektionszahlen wo die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken ja
noch relativ groß ist denn gerade solche
lockerungen vornehmen insofern ist es
kein geheimnis bad bank hat der autos
haben es gesagt dass ich meine fraktion
eine weitergehende maske pflicht
innenräume sehr gut hätte vorstellen
können und dass es dazu verschiedene
sichtweisen in der ampelkoalition gibt
aber richtig ist eben auch und darf es
zu recht hingewiesen und es ist nicht so
dass dieser gesetzentwurf keine
maßnahmen mehr ermöglicht die hotspot
regelung die unter beteiligung der
jeweiligen landtag und das ist doch
beste föderale demokratische tradition
mit zustimmung der landtage geschaffen
wird ermöglicht eben weitergehende
maßnahmen zum beispiel die von ihnen
geforderten maske pflichten auch in
innenräumen und ich finde es schon sehr
wichtig was der kollege wiese gesagt hat
wir sollten wir ein solcher verstanden
sie eine frage oder bemerkung aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion von denen schon
ich meine der demokratischen rechte herr
sorge da er
gerade darin mord vielen dank für ihre
ausführungen zur hotspot regelung wir
haben bereits in der ersten lesung im
deutschen bundestag als auch heute
unterschiedliche auffassungen aus der
ampel koalition zum thema hotspot gehört
es fehlen nur noch die ausführung der
grünen der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gesagt hotspot können ganze länder seien
auch die kollegin aus der spd hat in der
ersten lesung gesagt hotspot können
ganze länder seien ganze bundesländer
wie beispielsweise schleswig-holstein
sachsen-anhalt baden-württemberg die
freien demokraten sagen die
gebietskörperschaft ist der landkreis
vollkommen allein jetzt frage ich sie
wie sehen bündnis 90 die grünen dass bei
diesen instanzen bei diesen krankheits
belastung wie ist die sprenz scharfe
abgrenzung eines hotspots sind das ganze
bundesländer flächenbundesländer oder
sind das lediglich kleine städte und
kleine landkreise
vielen dank die berg kollege für die
frage weil es mir in der tat ermöglicht
einen wichtigen aspekten der debatte
noch mal näher zu erläutern sie kennen
genau wie ich den spruch ein blick ins
gesicht er leicht ins gesetz erleichtert
die rechtsfindung und im gesetz
und
und und wir setzen dem tat von
gebietskörperschaften die rede sie
wissen dass gebietskörperschaften städte
sein können gemeinde sein können lang
sein können aber das natürlich auch
länder gebietskörperschaften sind und
insofern
das ist das ist ihnen ja nichts neues
und insofern geht das gesetz mit dem
unbestimmten rechtsbegriffen die die
kriterien dastehen ist ja nicht nur ein
kriterium sind verschiedene kriterien
angelegt aufgrund welcher unbestimmten
rechtsbegriffe einen hotspot
festgestellt werden kann natürlich wird
es im regelfall so sein wenn sie sich
die inzidenz und auch die krankenhaus
belegung andere situation zusammen lang
anschauen das im regelfall hotspots auf
landkreise oder regionen begrenzt aber
natürlich ist nicht ausgeschlossen im
gesetz wenn sie insbesondere an die
bundesländer hamburg bremen oder auch
das saarland denken oder auch in
besonderen situationen weitere
bundesländer das ein ganzes bundesland
zum hotspot erklärt wird aber herr
kollege diese entscheidung und das finde
ich ausdrücklich richtig obliegt den
dafür gewählten landesparlamenten wir
als deutsche bundestag und die minister
westerwelle sollte sich davor hüten die
arbeit der landesparlamente gering zu
schätzen ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung
ich teile das er mit vier kolleginnen
kollegen hier im haus wie professionell
dort gearbeitet wird und darum sich den
richtigen händen
liebe
kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich habe es jetzt mehrfach ausgeführt
werden uns weitergehende maßnahmen
vorstellen können aber politik ist immer
auch die die kunst der kompromiss finden
und wir haben hier ein kompromiss
gefunden der handhabbar und händler ist
der den landtagen viel verantwortung
überträgt für die sie auch gewählt für
sie auch gewählt sind und wir haben aber
das ist mir noch wichtig zu betonen wir
haben die klare vereinbarung in der
ampelkoalition
und es gibt nach der bisherigen
zusammenarbeit auch keinen zweifel daran
dass diese vereinbarung gilt das wenn
wir feststellen kollege köhler hat sie
auch noch mal gesagt wenn wir
feststellen dass die heute zu
beschließenden regelungen dann eben doch
nicht ausreichend wenn wir feststellen
dass die sorgen die viele hier in der
heutigen debatte geäußert haben die
menschen draußen äußern dass die
berechtigt sind dann werden wir
natürlich als ampelkoalition das gesamte
das schnell noch mal zusammentreten und
gegebenenfalls nachbessern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen normalerweise
hofft man als politiker ja dass man
recht behält ich muss ihnen offen sagen
heute hoffe ich dass die kollegin
kapitals kollege autos schon ich unseren
und wir mit unseren befürchtungen und
sorgen nicht recht behalten aber wie
gesagt wenn es so ist als diese regeln
wenn es so ist dass diese regelung nicht
ausreichen dann werden wir hier schnell
noch mal zusammenkommen diese
handlungsfähigkeit haben wir den
vergangenen monaten bewiesen und wir
werden sie auch in den kommenden monaten
an den tag legen vielen dank wieder auf
der bundesgesetzgeber beschließt heute
den rahmen für das
infektionsschutzgesetz und deswegen ist
der hoffnung die rahmenbedingungen
festzulegen im
bundesgesundheitsministerium gab es in
der frage hotspot ein gutachten und dort
wurde dann festgelegt die kriterien
müssen möglichst eng und präzise
definiert sein und es gab dann
tatsächlich eine auseinandersetzung
zwischen den bundesjustizminister in dem
bundesgesundheitsminister was das damals
zu bedeuten hat karl lauterbach sie
haben uns sicherlich mitbekommen sieht
die möglichkeit dass einzelne länder zum
hot spot erklärt werden können genau wie
helge limburg der redner gerade der
bundesjustizminister sah das vor drei
tagen noch ganz anders wie das jetzt ist
bleibt unklar und das ist eine
diskussion die sicherlich gleich auch
unter den ministerpräsidenten in der
länderkammer die auch noch über dieses
gesetz
sitzung noch einmal zur sprache kommt
die unklare definition und der verweis
von hermle limburg auf die frage wer das
dann eigentlich genau fest zu denen hat
das dass die länderparlamente machen
sollen das ist natürlich muss ich es ist
der bundesgesetzgeber der dieses gesetz
hier einbringt länderparlamente können
nur den rahmen noch dann exekutieren
objekt definieren können das
wahrscheinlich wird es so sein da rein
so offen ist ist eine hotspot bewegung
agiert dass die eingeplante tatsächlich
aufgerufen sind um es dann selber zu
definieren so jetzt geht es hier weiter
in der debatte hat
für die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
diana stöcker sie ist mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle wissen
es seit monaten morgen am 19 drittel
läuft das infektionsschutzgesetz aus es
gab keinerlei vorausschauende
vorbereitung der ampelkoalition in einem
hauruck verfahren muss das gesetz in
fünf tagen durchgezogen werden im
ergebnis und ein handwerklich schlecht
es nicht ausgereiftes konzept das von
experten in der öffentlichen anhörung am
letzten montag auseinandergenommen wurde
von uns von ihnen bis heute nicht
wesentlich nachgebessert wurde einen
solch schlechten gesetzentwurf können
wir als unions fraktion nur ablehnen
auch die bundesländer sprechen sich
mehrheitlich dieses gesetz aus war
vorhin schon ein paar mal die rede davon
den kündigen bereits jetzt an dass sie
den aktuellen handlungsoptionen so lange
nutzen werden wie es irgend möglich ist
um die pandemie zu bekämpfen in der
öffentlichen debatte am mittwoch und
auch heute wieder haben wir abgeordnete
ihrer regierungskoalition gehört die
gesagt haben dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz ein großer
kompromiss der die ampel kreation
abbildet sie hätten sich ein anderes
gesetz gewünscht würden den ländern gern
einen breiteren instrumenten katalog zur
verfügung stellen aber diese
minimallösung sei eben demokratie
sprich es ist der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner der in ihrer koalition möglich
ist diesen satz werden wir meine
prognose noch öfter hören
demokratie heißt aber nicht nur einen
minimalkonsens in einer
regierungskoalition herzustellen sondern
mit verantwortung und vernunft
entscheidungen zu treffen und zu handeln
minister habeck sagte gestern bei seinem
statement zu impfpflicht in vorsorge-
und verantwortung denken aber beim
infektionsschutzgesetz gilt es plötzlich
nicht mehr sie haben die pflicht ältere
und immunschwache menschen zu schützen
aber sie heben die masken pflicht
weitgehend auf schaffen einen
flickenteppich und mit einer schwammigen
hotspots strategie wo gehobelt wird
fallen späne aber bei ihnen fällt
sprichwörtlich buchstäblich der ganze
komplette werkzeugkasten auseinander am
mittwoch habe ich mit dem leiter des
welcome centers für geflüchtete aus der
ukraine im berliner hauptbahnhof
gesprochen berichtete jeder dritte der
bislang 150000 geflüchteten aus der
ukraine hat ist positiv auf gruner
getestet menschen die in überfüllten
zügen unterwegs waren und nun in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften zusammenleben
und in dieser krise wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz auf ein minimum
reduziert nehmen sie von der
ampelkoalition diesen widerspruch
überhaupt war
wir befinden uns im krisenmodus schon in
normalen zeiten hatte sich nie
ausgezahlt abzuwarten aber die aktuelle
zögerliche haltung dass ständige auf der
bremse stehen wenn es um
vorausschauendes zupacken des handelns
halt handeln geht wird ihnen auf die
füße fallen sie sind sehenden auges in
diese situation rein gerasselt und sie
werden mit dem gesetzentwurf ihrer
verantwortung gegenüber der bevölkerung
nicht gerecht
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege jens pike für
die spd bot
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren heute
diskutieren wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz sowie weitere
gesetzliche regelungen zu einer dieser
regelung die verbesserung beim
kurzarbeitergeld möchte ich für meine
fraktion hier was sagen weil es für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
unserem land gerade in der jetzigen
situation von besonderer bedeutung ist
vor vier wochen haben wir hier im haus
die verlängerung der krisenbedingten
sonderregelung des kurzarbeitergeldes im
grundsatz beschlossen vor vier wochen
stand auch noch die vorsichtige
zuversicht dass eine erholung auf dem
arbeitsmarkt gibt und dass wir nicht
alle sonder regelungen die winterkrone
krise hatten weiter verlängern müssen
dass wir uns auf dem weg zur normalität
befinden sechs tage später
mit dem überfall putins auf die ukraine
ist eine rückkehr zur normalität in
weite ferne gerückt
präsident seelands er hat das hier
gestern in diesem haus sehr eindrücklich
geschildert und die schrecken des
krieges deutlich gemacht
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir handeln
die bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
sanktionen gegen das system putin auf
den weg gebracht das war notwendig und
das war richtig aber
krieg und sanktionen werden auch an uns
nicht spurlos vorbeigehen es fehlen
rohstoffe wegen mangelnder halbleiter
und kabelbäume musste die autoindustrie
bereits zu drosseln in teilen einstellen
sind davon ausgehen dass bis juni
400.000 1 5 millionen fahrzeuge das
entspricht zehn prozent jährliche
produktion wenig geklärt werden können
heute morgen ticker dass das bad
mangel hat dieser stillstand kostet auch
uns aber eins darf auf keinen fall
kosten und das sind arbeitsplätze
deswegen
hilft das wort zu allen vor allem monat
zu grundüberzeugung dieser
regierungskoalition gesagt habe auch
heute wir lassen niemanden im stich
deshalb werden wir die leiharbeit mit
der änderung die wir hiermit beschließen
wieder in das kurzarbeitergeld aufnehmen
denn der ukraine krieg ist kein branche
liches risiko und der automobilindustrie
auf den einsatz von
leiharbeitnehmerinnen und arbeiten
jemand angewiesen weiter ermöglichen wir
der bundesregierung bei
außergewöhnlichen verhältnissen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt schnell zu reagieren um per
rechtsverordnung die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
wieder teilweise oder auch vollständig
zu erstatten denn es ist vollkommen klar
und das sind uns einig wir alle können
nicht vorhersehen wie sich dieser
konflikt entwickeln wird und was da auf
ihn zukommt mit dieser massnahme stellen
wir die handlungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung im ernstfall sicher in
sozialpolitik darf nicht immer nur
hinten dran denkt und reparatur politik
sein sondern sie muss vorausschauend
agieren
haben wir alle wissen die erstattung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge kann teuer
sein
bundesminister hat in seiner rede vor
vier wochen hier deutlich gemacht dass
die 26 milliarden rücklage der ba
aufgebraucht sind kurzarbeit hat bisher
42 milliarden euro gekostet aber uns
auch eins wichtig ebenso wenig wie bei
der äußeren sicherheit darf man eher
sozialen sicherheit und dem inneren
zusammenhalt unserem land sparen
und deshalb
bin ich zum schluss meiner rede blickte
noch einmal auf die nächste woche in der
wir hier im bundestag über den haushalt
sprechen werden und ich sage ganz
deutlich wir dürfen nicht nur auf die
ausgaben schauen sondern auch auf die
einnahmen wir brauchen geld um diese
herausfordern das sage ich ganz klar
starke schultern müssen mehr tragen als
schwache danke ihnen stimmen
jens böcker das für die spd mit dem
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales der
bundestag debattiert und zweiter dritter
lesung die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
normalerweise würden alle regelungen am
samstagabend auf sonntag auslaufen der
gesetzgeber lässt jetzt hier gang
gesetzt dass es einen basisschutz gibt
krankenhäuser pflegeheime von
asylbewerbern und öffentlichem
nahverkehr werden weiter masken getragen
es sind auch test nicht möglich
und in hotspots gibt es eine
sonderregelung wenn es dann doch zum
rechnung kommt ja vor der arena will
viel schneller für die
einigkeit darüber zu bestehen dass es
unterstützungsmaßnahmen gibt die es gilt
zu verlängern so auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetzes
dass wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode bereits auf den weg
gebracht haben und dass ja die
zielrichtung hatte gerade einrichtungen
der
arbeitsmarktpolitik der rehabilitation
und der behindertenhilfe finanziell zu
unterstützen
damit sie aufgrund der einschränkenden
maßnahmen die sie hatten durch die
korona pandemie finanziell nicht in die
schieflage geraten und auch weiterhin
bestehen können und
das gesetz hat in seiner wirkung auch
gezeigt dass es richtig war dies zu
machen und dass die wirkungen auch
entsprechend da waren wenn man sieht
dass etwa 25.000 anträge gestellt worden
sind und ja
auch bewilligt worden sind einrichtungen
eben nicht schließen sondern eben
weiterhin auch arbeiten können unter
erschwerten maßnahmen aber auch
existieren können so war das
unwahrscheinlich wichtig und richtig
dieses gesetz damals zu machen und auch
wenn jetzt die
einschränkenden maßnahmen vielleicht
zurückgenommen werden so steht ja aber
auch im infektionsschutzgesetz und dass
die länder ja gegebenenfalls ja die
maßnahme wieder aufgreifen können und da
jetzt vorsorge zu betreiben
damit dieses gesetz an außen fortwirken
kann wenn die länder sich für solche
schritte entscheiden halten wir von der
cdu csu fraktion für vollkommen richtig
und unterstützen damit auch diese
verlängerung des sozialdienstleister
einsatz gesetzes neben
neben dieser maßnahme werden aber auch
weitere oder sonder regelungen durch
eine verordnungsermächtigung eben auch
verlängert und das halten wir auch für
wichtig ich darf sie in kürze auf zähne
arbeitsschutz rechtliche grundlagen für
betriebliche infektions maßnahmen oder
corona bedingter anpassungen von
vergütungsvereinbarungen zwischen den
trägern der zugelassenen vorsorge und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen und den
krankenkassen oder zb den einsatz von
vorsorge- und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen als ersatz
krankenhäuser bei pandemie bedingter
kapazitätsengpässen zugelassener
krankenhäuser das zeigt dass der
maßnahmenkatalog vollumfänglich
erweitert wird und verlängert wird das
finden wir gut für die zukunft hoffen
wir dass eine weitere verlängerung jetzt
nicht nötig wäre weil das würde bedeuten
dass die lage sich verbessert aber wenn
es noch absehbar ist dass es eben nicht
der fall ist dann bitten wir darum diese
verlängerungs gesetze vielleicht auch
frühzeitiger einzubringen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren mit der letzte
redner hier in der debatte ist erwin
rüddel von der cdu/csu in der
40 des gesundheitsausschusses und danach
kommt es hier zur namentlichen
abstimmung meine damen und herren der
vorliegende gesetzentwurf der koalition
macht einigermaßen ratlos denn die
intention ist grundsätzlich richtig
im gegensatz zur umsetzung natürlich ist
es richtig nach zwei jahren an demi
bedingter einschränkung den weg zurück
in die normalität zu finden und
natürlich ist es sinnvoll
weitere lockerung zu beschließen und die
masken pflicht zum beispiel den schulen
und kitas abzuschaffen die verhältnisse
haben sich gravierend
verändert wir haben impfstoffe wir haben
medikamente und wir haben eine mutation
die milde verläufe
vorzeigt wir müssen lernen mit dem virus
zu leben und die einschränkungen im
alltag müssen möglichst auf ein minimum
reduziert werden soweit so gut aber
handwerklich ist der vorliegende entwurf
eine katastrophe
inhaltliche unklarheiten und präzise
formulierungen
unterschiedliche interpretationen aus
der den reihen der koalition das alles
summiert sich zu einem abbild der
zerrissenheit der ampel in dieser frage
ob es um fehlende definitionen für
klinik überlastungen geht ob es um die
hotspot regelung geht ob es um die rolle
der landtage geht überall fehlt es an
klarheit und an schlüssigen vorgaben die
verlängerung der übergangszeiten durch
diverse ländern gibt bereits einen
vorgeschmack auf das was uns
künftig erwarten wird verschlimmert wird
alles nur noch durch den
gesundheitsminister der trägt
zuverlässig zur weiteren verunsicherung
der menschen bei indem er den kompromiss
der koalition
gleichzeitig lobt und schlecht redet
anstatt wenigstens zu versuchen die
mühsame reinigung der ampel verständlich
zu kommunizieren
redet der minister so als wenn er in
opposition zu dem antrag stehen würde so
kann das nicht weitergehen
andere länder in europa haben viel
früher geöffnet doch der minister
beschwört mit vorliebe unseren angeblich
schlechten corona status übrigens in
seiner amtszeit unser gesundheitssystem
verkraftet auch das weil die institute
geben nicht gleichbedeutend ist mit
überforderung
entscheidend ist die tatsächliche
belastung des gesundheitssystems meine
damen und herren ich bin grundsätzlich
für mehr mut und für mehr freiheit in
eigenverantwortung
deshalb hätte ich gern diesem antrag
zugestimmt der vorliegende entwurf macht
es mir aber leider unmöglich
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und anderer vorschriften der ausschuss
für gesundheit empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf den drucksachen
1070 und
1094 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
der spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
auf drucksachen
958 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
mir liegt eine vielzahl von erklärungen
nach § 31 unserer geschäftsordnung vor
entsprechend unserer geschäftsordnung
neben wir diese erklärung zu protokoll
ich werde nun diejenigen die den
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
dankeschön bestimmt dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich niemand der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
tschuldigung
der gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung
mit den stimmen der fraktionen der spd
bündnis 90 die grünen und der fdp gegen
die stimmen der cdu csu fraktion der afg
fraktion und der fraktion die linke
angenommen bei enthaltung des
abgeordneten matthias birkwald
dritte beratung und schlussabstimmung
die fraktionen der cdu/csu und der afg
haben namentliche abstimmung verlangt
die abstimmung erfolgt in der west lobby
sie haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
der abstimmung 20 minuten zeit bitte
denken sie daran dass wir unmittelbar
nach eröffnung der namentlichen
abstimmung noch weitere abstimmungen
durchführen werden man hat ja und hier
sehen sie wie west lobby die
abgeordneten haben sich schon vor den
ohren versammelt also dieses wichtige
gesetz das hat die opposition verlangt
mussten namentlich abgestimmt werden ein
bisschen misslich aber wir haben es ja
noch relativ früh am tag den der
bundesrat kommt heute zu einer
sondersitzung zusammen und muss diesem
gesetz ja auch noch zustimmen und wird
das wohl auch tun denn es ist ein
einspruchgesetz verschlimmert erklärt in
der bundesrat dieses neue gesetz
sozusagen in den vermittlungsausschuss
holen würde dann würde die klärung
dieser sache so lange dauern dass die
übergangsfristen die meisten länder
ziehen wollen bis anfang april wissen
zweiter punkt dann schon längst vorbei
wäre und insofern wird das im bundesrat
sicherlich klar gehen hier im bundestag
hat die ampel eine ordentliche mehrheit
nicht alle waren so richtig überzeugt
aber im notfall steht natürlich die
während die abgeordneten hier ihre
kärtchen in die urne werfen auf den
karten steht dann der jeweilige name des
abgeordneten man kann das dann auch
später in den protokollen nachlesen wer
wie abgestimmt hat also wenig hier
abgestimmt wurde ist es so dass wir
jetzt hier bei dem gesetzentwurf der spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp sind ein
entwurf des gesetzes zur verlängerung
des sozialdienstleister entgelt gesetzes
und weiterer regelungen das wird hier
ganz normal abgestimmt und wir hören mal
zu wie die abstimmung ausgegangen ist
wir wiederholen die veranstaltung und
die abstimmung und stellen protokoll
sicher das ergebnis fest ich bitte
diejenigen die den gesetzentwurf in der
ausschuss fassung es handelt sich um die
verlängerung des
sozialdienstleister einsatz gesetzes und
weiterer regelungen zustimmen wollen
nochmals um das handzeichen
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen die
cdu csu fraktion und die fraktion die
linke wer stimmt dagegen
niemand mehr enthält sich die afg
fraktion danke der gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter beratung angenommen
wichtig ist gesetzt und sie merken es
die teile der opposition stimmen damit
da geht es unter anderem um die
geltenden leistungen gewährt werden
müssen aufgrund der pandemie dass die
auch fortgesetzte werden und dieses
gesetz wird hier eine mehrheit gekommen
bei enthaltung der fdp fraktion
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 21 c
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
gesundheit zu der verordnung der
bundesregierung zur änderung der cobit
19 schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
1062 der verordnung auf drucksache 952
zuzustimmen wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung
die koalitionsfraktionen und die
fraktion die linke wer stimmt dagegen
die afg fraktion wer enthält sich die
fraktionen der cdu/csu
die beschlussempfehlung ist damit
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 21 die abstimmung
über die beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für familie senioren frauen
und jugend sowie im antrag der fraktion
der cdu/csu mit dem titel
einkommensausfälle für junge eltern beim
elterngeld auffangen corona bedingte
elterngeld regelungen verlängern der
ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
1063 den antrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf drucksache 1007 abzulehnen
während petra pau sich hier durch die
verschiedenen anlagen die wir alle
abgestimmt werden müssen langsam
fortbewegt thema dort können wir noch
mal festhalten die
abgeordneten sind jetzt aufgerufen in
den nächsten 30 minuten hier abzustimmen
über den gesetzentwurf der spd bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp zum entwurf eines
gesetzes zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und anderer
vorschriften namentlich hier draußen im
foyer da ist es schon etwas leerer
geworden viele abgeordnete haben direkt
in den ersten minuten ihre karten an die
urnen geworfen
hinten sehen sie das noch übrigens am
bildschirmrand hinter der glasscheibe da
ist dahinter stehen dann die ohren und
die schwierigkeit ist bei solchen
längeren abstimmung auch für das
präsidium das natürlich auch zahlreiche
abgeordnete vonnöten sind um hier die
normalen abstimmungen durchzuführen
viele die hier noch im plenarsaal sitzen
die haben noch nicht abgestimmt andere
wie sehen sie jetzt hier gerade schön im
flur stehen beisammen haben ihre
kroatischen eingeworfen hat er eben noch
mal über die debatte und andere dinge so
ist das üblich mittlerweile übrigens
auch alle wieder relativ dicht und nahe
zusammen der bundestag hat ja auch
gelockert die tribüne wurde abgeschafft
in der nicht die ernste bisher platz
nehmen mussten sie dürfen jetzt wieder
ins plenum die masken pflicht allerdings
ist hier im hohen hause immer noch
vonnöten und sie sehen es ja auch schon
seit heute morgen die abstandsregelung
ist seit dieser woche ich glaube schon
seit mittwoch ist das richtig erinnere
aufgehoben worden auch im plenarsaal
also die stühle sind auch nebeneinander
häufig besitzt das war ja in der letzten
zeit nicht so also der bundestag hat ja
auch die lokalen eben gerade auch das
bundestagspräsidium arg gebeutelt ist
durch die hohe infektionen bärbel bas
die ministerpräsidentin ich habe es
erlebt hat gruner drei ihrer
stellvertreterinnen und stellvertreter
am kohona
von mack war es die cdu stellvertreter
ist etwas anderen krank auch für sie
gute besserung und insofern bleiben nur
noch zwei übrig die hier die sitzung
leiten das ist katrin göring eckardt die
irgendein gleich mal petra pau ablösen
wird und petra pau kämpft sich
mittlerweile hier weiter durch die
abstimmung im moment sind wir
war zusatzpunkt 17
alle kroner maßnahmen für kinder sofort
beenden das kindeswohl bei allen kohler
maßnahmen prüfen von der afg ein antrag
den ich vorhin schon mal zitierte die
haft die hat in diesem antrag unter
anderem jahr festgehalten der bundestag
möge in einer sondersitzung
zusammenkommen und sich bei den kindern
entschuldigt
das ergebnis der namentlichen
schlussabstimmung über den gesetzentwurf
wird ihnen erst nachdem tagesordnung
22 mitgeteilt im anschluss daran folgt
die abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge
ich bitte das bei ihren weiteren
planungen für diesen tag zu
berücksichtigen ich rufe auf die
tagesordnungspunkte
22 und 22 b beratung der anträge der
fraktionen der cdu/csu mit den titeln
durch technologieoffenheit die
transformationen der automobilindustrie
beschleunigen und die klimaschutzziele
erreichen und tempo machen bei
verkehrsprojekten
weitere beschleunigungs potenziale heben
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen ich bitte nun die
plätze 1 und jetzt geht es zunächst mal
weiter transformationen der
automobilindustrie mit verkehrsprojekten
unterm strich fordert die unionsfraktion
einen transformationsprozess der die
automobilindustrie und die verbraucher
mit einbezieht dazu legt sie einen 18
punkte einplanen in ihrem antrag vor
unter anderem soll die bundesregierung
zur technologieoffenheit im
motorisierten individualverkehr und zu
allen zur verfügung stehenden
instrumenten technologien sich bekennen
dazu soll auch schnell eine strategie
her mit klaren maßnahmen um die ziele zu
erreichen als übergangstechnologie
sollen weiterhin plug-in-hybride
berücksichtigt werden fordert die union
langfristig sollen aber technologien und
alternativen wie wasserstoff und
regenerative kraftstoffe gefördert
werden und christoph ploß er ist der cdu
vorsitzende des landesverbandes hamburg
und mitglied im verkehrsausschuss hat
jetzt als erster hier das wort
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen der angriffskrieg von putin
russland auf die ukraine der wirft auch
bei uns in deutschland fragen im
hinblick auf die mobilität auf viele
fragen sich gerade in diesen tagen wie
kann tanzen wieder bezahlbar werden und
wie senken wir die hohen spritkosten da
will ich zu beginn der debatte eines
einmal ganz klar in richtung der
ampelkoalition sagen sie sollten sofort
die steuern senken sie sollten aufhören
sich in bürokratischen debatten zu
verheddern sie sollen aufhören damit
dass eine hand nicht weiß was die andere
in der regierung tut wie zum beispiel am
letzten sonntag als christian lindner
mit dem vorschlag eines tankstellen
rabatz kommt und ihm am selben tag der
robert habeck widerspricht das was wir
jetzt brauchen das ist klarheit das ist
nicht bürokratie sondern das sind
steuersenkungen damit tanken in
deutschland wieder bezahlbar wird meine
damen und herren
und damit verbunden sind auch andere
fragen die wir hier mit dem antrag im
deutschen bundestag als cdu csu fraktion
beantworten wollen wie können wir
unabhängig vom russischen gas werden wie
können wir unabhängig von russischem öl
werden auch im mobilitätsbereich wie
können wir es schaffen co2 im
mobilitätssektor zu reduzieren
entscheidende fragen auf die wir
antworten finden müssen und wir haben
auch dazu eine klare meinung wir sagen
wir wollen
technologieoffen an dieses große thema
an diese große herausforderung angehen
und da muss ich sagen hätte ich mir
gerade von der fdp mehr glaubwürdigkeit
in den vergangenen wochen gewünscht im
wahlkampf haben sie noch stimmung
gemacht und gesagt bitte nicht nur rein
auf batterieantrieb sich konzentrieren
wir können die klimaschutz ziele nur
erreichen wir können die deutsche
automobilindustrie nur stark machen wenn
wir technologieoffen rangehen das waren
die aussagen im wahlkampf kurz danach
kassiert verkehrsminister volker wissing
genau das in einem interview im
tagesspiegel
und es gibt unterschiedliche aussagen
aus der ampel koalition bis hin dazu
dass gestern ganz stolz von der
bundesregierung eine pressemitteilung
herausgegeben wird das das ende des
verbrennungsmotors bevorstehen das ist
genau das gegenteil dessen liebe
kollegin der fdp was sie im wahlkampf
versprochen haben und
ich möchte ihn deswegen eines auch bei
der gelegenheit ins stammbuch schreiben
und hoffe dass sie deswegen auf unseren
antrag heute unterstützen werden es ist
nicht die frage setzen wir auf batterie
antriebe setzen wir auf wasserstoff
setzen wir auf klimaneutrale kraftstoffe
wie fuels setzen wir auch biokraftstoffe
wir werden alle zur verfügung stehenden
werkzeuge alle zur verfügung stehenden
instrumente benötigen damit wir die
klimaschutzziele erreichen und damit die
deutschen autobauer und damit die
zulieferer auch in den nächsten jahren
stark sein können und damit
arbeitsplätze in deutschland erhalten
werden
und das ist verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen deswegen nicht eine frage des
entweder oder entweder batterie oder
wasserstoff entweder batterie oder if
you sondern es ist eine frage des
sowohl-als-auch und daher kann ich nur
sagen sie brauchen
und wir müssen es schaffen gleiche
rahmenbedingungen
für alle klimafreundlichen technologien
in deutschland zu gewährleisten alle
müssen die gleiche ausgangslage haben
wir müssen die gleichen chancen haben
und wir brauchen im besten sinne des
wortes einen wettbewerb der
klimafreundlichen technologien in
deutschland
und daher ist es auch falsch was sie in
den letzten tagen erneut mehrfach zum
ausdruck gebracht haben das ende des
verbrennungsmotors einzuläuten denn wir
werden selbst wenn wir alle e auto ziele
erreichen wofür wir als cdu csu fraktion
sehr sind wenn wir immer noch über 35
millionen verbrenner in den zwanzig 30er
jahren auf deutschlands straßen haben
auch die müssen klimaneutral werden wenn
wir die klimaschutzziele erreichen
wollen wenn sie mit einem unternehmen
wie porsche sprechen dann sagen die
ihnen genau das die sagen nicht setzt
nur auf batterie- oder setzt nur auf
apples sondern ein unternehmen wie
porsche sagt wir brauchen beides wir
brauchen gute rahmenbedingungen für
batterie antriebe und wir brauchen gute
politische rahmenbedingungen auch für
events und deswegen
unterstützen wir unseren antrag setzen
sie sich für technologieoffenheit
einsetzen sie sich für soziale
marktwirtschaft einsetzen sie sich für
mehr forschung in battery in wasserstoff
in klimaneutrale kraftstoffe 1 gehen sie
weg von ihrer ideologie das sage ich
gerade in hinblick auf die fdp und
kommen sie wieder auf einen klaren
bürgerlichen pfad zurück herzlichen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
des opfers hatte den antrag der cdu csu
vorgespielt eines uns jetzt zwei anträge
und die abgeordnete haben immer noch
zeit abzustimmen noch gute fünf minuten
sind vorgesehen für die nördliche
stimmen und
jürgen berghahn für die spd mitglied im
verkehrsausschuss heute in seiner ersten
rede kommt jetzt hier zu wort
[Applaus]
an der a45 zeigt sehr deutlich dass wir
waren thema planungsbeschluss
aber die letzten wochen zeigen auch dass
die bundesregierung genau dies tut das
verkehrsministerium hat letzte woche das
zukunftspaket leistungsfähige
autobahnbrücke und vorgelegt und mit dem
darin enthalten und neun punkte plan
wirklich eine zeitenwende eingeleitet
der einsatz modernster digitaler
technologien bessere kommunikation und
abstimmung zwischen allen beteiligten
sowie eine zukunftsgerichtete planung
sind nur einige aspekte die wir
verbessern und voranbringen werden
das klingt ziemlich nackt aber wir haben
einen sehr konkreten fahrplan
ausgearbeitet und setzten diesen bei den
planungen zur ramme talbrücke um
womöglich laufen auch planungen prozesse
beteiligungsverfahren parallel
zueinander in die planungsphase deutlich
zu verkürzen
es ist wirklich interessant dass jetzt
ausgerechnet von der cdu tempo bei
verkehrsprojekten verlangt wird denn uns
abgeordnete aus nrw was ich natürlich
genau das nrw seit inzwischen fünf
jahren von der cdu regiert wird ganz
offensichtlich wurde bei der talbrücke
damals von verkehrsminister hendrik wüst
nicht vorausschauend geplant
heißt es jetzt einfach auf die
bundesregierung zu zeigen und mehr
einsatz zu verlangen sie haben für die
heutige sitzung an den antrag
eingereicht in dem einige gute maßnahmen
sicher enthalten sind die werden wir
auch entsprechend berücksichtigen aber
bitte haben sie denn ihre zeit vergessen
wo es csu bundesverkehrsminister waren
und die hätten diese dinge auch schon
längst umsetzen können
insgesamt gesehen ist der antrag ein
riesiges sammelsurium altbekannter wenig
strategische ansätze und wurde
offensichtlich nur gestellt um die
koalition auf angebliche versäumnisse
hinzuweisen wie es ja aber nicht gibt
dieses beispiel und auch das gesamte
thema planung zu beschleunigen sich
jedoch nicht für den wahlkampf oder
konfrontation keine partei keine partei
hat in der vergangenheit alles richtig
gemacht sie können sich aber darauf
verlassen dass die spd und die koalition
alles dafür tun wird prozessen so weit
wie möglich und sinnvoll zu
beschleunigen
bitte bedenken sie auch dass das thema
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
und bürger alle wahlkreise
stadland vielleicht auch die baustelle
vor ihrer eigenen haustüre
dementsprechend wünsche ich mir dass wir
probleme als gemeinsame probleme
erkennen und die dann auch gemeinsam
gelöst werden können
natürlich müssen nicht nur brücken
sondern auch straßen radwege schienen
wasserstraßen zügig modernisiert werden
und es muss nicht nur im verkehrswegen
wesen sondern auch in bereichen umwelt
digitalisierung und energie tempo
gemacht werden für die zentralen
vorhaben der bundesregierung geht es gar
nicht anders nur so können wir können
wir eine digitalisierte gesellschaft die
klimaschutzziele und den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien erreichen
gerade die erneuerbaren energien sind
derzeit in aller munde der schlimme
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine zeigt sehr
deutlich dass wir zu lange auf vertraute
mittel gesetzt und zu wenig auf unsere
unabhängigkeit geachtet haben
dementsprechend sollten wir diesen weg
auf alle us das ernst nehmen und auch in
diesem bereich planung deutlich
beschleunigen
es geht nicht nur mehr um nachhaltigkeit
sondern auch um die eigene sicherheit im
wohlstand und damit den zukunft unseres
landes
deshalb werden wir noch vor ostern erste
gesetzliche vorgaben verabschieden muss
unsere energieversorgung auch für die
zukunft zu sichern
anschließend wird die koalition bis
herbst weitere gesetzliche maßnahmen zur
planungs beschleunigung und
strukturanpassung verabschieden und
endgültig beschließen
viele kolleginnen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sie sehen dass wir aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen tempo machen
müssen um zukunftsfähig zu sein und zu
bleiben um nachhaltiger zu werden
selbstverständlich auch um unserer
verantwortung den bürgerinnen und
bürgern gegenüber gerecht zu werden
vielen dank
[Applaus]
man könnte auch sagen wir quatschen
machen so wie es die koalition und die
bundesregierung mache vielen dank
seitdem gehörten sie redet im sommer
fortgesetzt hat also in japan hat es am
anfang angesprochen da wurde ich darauf
hinaus die bundeseigene autobahn gmbh
gmbh hat eine deutschlandweite analyse
vorgenommen von 52.000 386 sogenannten
teil bauwerken sind 8000 so marode dass
sie ausgebessert oder erneuert werden
müssen 4000 drücken sollte der
bundesverkehrsminister jetzt beschlossen
sollen bis 2030 erneuert werden ab 20 26
sollen dafür nun 25 milliarden statt
eine milliarden euro investieren der
spanier für die algarve
das was hier zu grunde liegt der ganzen
diskussion ist die verkehrswende das ist
ein politisches projekt auf eu-ebene und
ziel dieses projektes ist autofahren
also individualverkehr immer
unbezahlbarer und unattraktiver zu
machen und das passiert auf europäischer
ebene mit der flottenverbrauch vorgabe
der europäischen union die den antrieb
von fahrzeugen mit verbrennungsmotoren
perspektivisch unmöglich macht ob sich
jetzt verbieten oder nicht es ist so die
verbrauchsvorgaben sind nicht zu
erfüllen jetzt gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten die eine sprechen sie
jahren das ist die transformation der
automobilindustrie hin zu
elektromobilität
das geht einher mit einem kompetenz
wechsel in der industrie hin von also
von metall verarbeitender industrie hin
zur elektrochemie und da muss jeder
wissen der sich damit auskennen die war
haben sie wahrscheinlich jetzt die
rückmeldung gekriegt das geht in der
praxis überhaupt nicht die
mittelständische industrie die heute
metallteile bearbeitet kann keine zellen
herstellen das ist eine komplett
infantile vorstellung das heißt es geht
einher mit massiven arbeitsplatzverlust
die alternative dazu dass es im grunde
genommen unser programm das ist die
anerkennung synthetischer kraftstoffe
auf den flottenverbrauch auf
europäischer ebene
das ist politik der afg von tag eins da
brauchen sie gar keine transformation
der automobilindustrie
konkret zu ihrem antrag jetzt also sie
fordern im ersten schritt die
transformation hin zu
eine transformation der
automobilindustrie und dann haben sie
unter punkt 5 das abgeschrieben was wir
hier seit tag eins fordern die
anerkennung synthetischer kraftstoffe
auf den flottenverbrauch da freue ich
mich darüber dass sie das übernommen
haben die fdp hat ja auch schon
übernommen gehabt in forderung aber dann
müssen sie auch konsequent sein es ist
nicht so dass man dann auch
technologische vorgaben machen muss wie
hier die plug in hybride noch fördern
das ist totaler unsinn und ganz ehrlich
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn sie diesen
antrag ernst gemeint hätten und hier
nicht sofort abstimmung beantragt hätten
sondern wir das in den ausschüssen
diskutiert hätten da hätten wir sehr
wohl eine gemeinsame position finden
können das hier ist so wir hier heute
abgestimmt wird ein schaufensterantrag
von ihnen um die gemüter in den ländern
beruhigen damit sie eben auch das gefühl
haben die cdu interessiert sich
überhaupt für die arbeitsplätze
tatsache ist tatsache ist es wird nicht
anders gehen wenn man die arbeitsplätze
erhalten will wird es in diesem land
nicht anders gehen als genau der politik
linie die wir vertreten haben zu folgen
dass man die synthetische kraftstoffe
anerkennt so ich komme jetzt noch zu
ihrem zweiten antrag das ist ja da
betrifft es mit recht die komplett
verfehlte infrastrukturpolitik der
letzten jahre gerade was das thema
straßenbau angeht sie machen eine
generalabrechnung sie machen eine
generalabrechnung und das ganze ist
deshalb ein treppenwitz weil genau diese
politik die sie hier kritisieren wie
haben sie die letzten zwölf jahre
elementar mitgestaltet sie können nicht
den menschen erzählen dass ich jetzt
alles anders machen würden wo sie nichts
mehr zu sagen haben das ist doch ein
witz und das wissen sie ja auch das
heißt tatsächlich ist es aber so dass in
ihrem ansatz speziell in dem zweiten
antrag den sie hier gestellt haben da
finden wir sehr viele konstruktive
elemente die übrigens auch die politik
und die anträge der afg widerspiegeln
und deshalb können wir ihnen hier sagen
diesen zweiten antrag zur beschleunigung
der infrastrukturmaßnahmen und der
veränderung der gesetzgebung dem stimmen
wir vollumfänglich zu das ist genau das
was wir immer gefordert haben und zu dem
ersten antrag wie gesagt wenn wir selbst
hören den ganzen ideologischen ballast
gehen sie da eingebaut haben befreit
bleibt dieser antrag in sich unlogisch
wir wollen keine transformation der
automobilindustrie wir wollen die
arbeitsplätze erhalten und deshalb
können wir im antrag selbstverständlich
so nicht zustimmen ich hätte mich
gefreut wir hätten in dem ausschuss
beraten werden bestimmt so geändert
gekriegt dass wir tatsächlich hier auch
zugestimmt hätten vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich konnte zunächst noch mal zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 21a die zeit für die
namentliche abstimmung ist gleich vorbei
und ich frage ist dennoch ein mitglied
des hauses anwesend dass seine stimme
nicht abgegeben hat
tatsächlich
fix die waldfee
gut dann
hatten wir noch einen redebeitrag lang
uns der kommt von nico slavik für
bündnis 90 die grünen und das ist ihre
erste rede auf die wir uns sehr freuen
bei uns geblieben
den
vorsitz
abgeschlagen von den beatles
sehr geehrte abgeordnete sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin lieber herr prof 16
jahre haben sie regiert cdu/csu zwölf
jahre lang davon das verkehrsministerium
und was ist ihre bilanz sie haben
millionen menschen in deutschland
abhängig gemacht vom auto weil wir die
alternativen vernachlässigt haben schien
und öpnv ausbau vollkommen vergessen
dienstwagen fed gefördert aber menschen
in bus bahn und rad im regen stehen
gelassen dafür zahlen gerade millionen
menschen hierzulande einen hohen preis
an der zapfsäule und die öl-milliarden
die lieben dann auch noch in putins
kriegskasse weil wir ein drittel unseres
rohöls aus russland beziehen so kann
darf und wird es nicht weitergehen
sie predigen hier heute wieder das
märchen von der technologieoffenheit
dabei haben wir alles was wir brauchen
schon heute die e autos kommen ob sie
wollen oder nicht eine stärkung von
china bus und rad ist fürs klima
unverzichtbar und das deutsche asknet
hätten wir ihn sehen wir endlich einen
fokus auf die sanierung legen statt uns
in überdimensionierten neubauten
festzubeißen
und hier komme ich nämlich zu ihrem
zweiten start man muss sich schon sehr
wundern dass cdu/csu heute den
schlechten zustand unserer infrastruktur
beklagen obwohl sie genau 16 jahre dafür
zeit gehabt hätten dass sie sich heute
hier hinstellen und als dritter der
deutschen verkehrsinfrastruktur
darstellen ist schon ziemlich peinlich
was haben sie stattdessen gemacht vor
allem viele ungelöste baustellen
hinterlassen
tausende brücken hierzulande sind
dringend sanierungsbedürftig
bekannt ist das nicht erst seit gestern
nicht erst seit der rahmede talbrücke
und der sperrung der a 45 bekannt ist
dass seit vielen jahren und csu kollege
andreas scheuer hat das problem
ignoriert ihr cdu kollege aus nrw
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst jahrelang
verkehrsminister in nrw hat das problem
ignoriert wir wissen aus dem nrw-landtag
dass straßen nrw unter der führung von
herrn wüst die instandhaltung der
rahmede talbrücke 20 17 herunterstufte
obwohl bekannt war wie gefährlich das
sein könnte
herunterstufte zugunsten von hunderten
neubauprojekten und damit die nötige
sanierung vertagte jahrelang haben
cdu/csu die verkehrsplanung zugunsten
100 neubau und erweiterungsprojekte
aufgebläht
1300 fern- straßenprojekte 850 kilometer
neue autobahn nur haben sie dabei
vergessen tausende brücken in
deutschland zu sanieren das rächt sich
jetzt ich weiß wovon ich rede ich komme
aus leverkusen die leverkusener
rheinbrücke war so macht wurde dass sie
jetzt neu gebaut wird und zwar als
doppelbrücke mit zwölf fahrspuren auch
hier grüßt der erweiterungsbau in zwölf
fahrspuren über den rhein das nenne ich
mal eine ich setze riesen autobahn
schade nur dass es da auch noch eine
andere krise gibt die klimakrise und die
ukraine krise beides fliegt uns jetzt im
verkehrssektor um die ohren dank 16
jahren völlig verfehlte verkehrspolitik
von ihnen wir werden es anders machen
vielen dann
so viel applaus wenige slavik ihre erste
reise und jetzt dürfte die abstimmung
zurück zu tagesordnungspunkt 21a und
frage erneut ist noch ein mitglied des
hauses anwesend dass seine stimmkarte
nicht abgeben konnte das ist jetzt nicht
mehr der fall dann schließlich die
abstimmung und bitte die schriftführerin
und schriftführer mit der auszahlung zu
beginnen das ergebnis wird ihnen erst
nach tagesordnungspunkt 22 bekannt
gegeben
und ich komme zurück zu unserer debatte
und das ergebnis steht und gegen 12 uhr
25 26 ungefähr fest da haben sich dann
bereits auf die ministerpräsidenten im
bundesrat versammelt und warten
natürlich auf dieses ergebnis denn dann
müssen die bundesländer abständen aber
zunächst geht es hier weiter mit der
transformation der automobilindustrie
und den ring und thomas lutze
da ich das für ein sehr wichtiges thema
halte vor allen dingen übersicht der
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer es geht
hier um die zukunft der
automobilindustrie das ist von meinen
vorrednern vorräten richtig festgehalten
worden und es geht darum wie gehen wir
damit um dass hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze bundesweit zur disposition
stehen und dass das arbeitsplätze sind
in der regel tarifgebunden und dann ig
metall überdurchschnittlich bezahlt
werden der antrag der union
sehen uns wieder richtige sachen drin
ist aber hochinteressant
nämlich genau dieses thema der
arbeitsplätze sie haben dann ranking sie
machen 18 punkte und machen da quasi im
ranking mit auch mit der nummerierung
und das thema arbeitsplätze in sage und
schreibe top 17 also da muss für meine
begriffe mal allen beteiligten klar an
welchen stellenwert die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in diesen betrieben bei
ihnen bei der union haben nämlich so gut
wie gar keine das geht überhaupt nicht
sich selber ich lebe seitwärts drei
jahrzehnten im saarland das ist mein
neues zuhause seit vielen jahren dort
gibt es mehrere zehntausend
arbeitsplätze den bereich das ist ford
in saarlouis zf in saarbrücken bosch
oder schaeffler in homburg um die großen
zu nennen aber es gibt auch viele
mittelständische unternehmen und vor
allem was oft vergessen wird auch viele
service unternehmen die davon abhängig
sind von der jetzigen automobilindustrie
man muss den wählerinnen und wählern die
ihn genau neun tagen sagen es runde
gerufen werden dann schon mal genau
sagen welche politik hier im deutschen
bundestag die union verfolgt schließlich
stellen sie dann noch den
ministerpräsidenten ich hoffe dass sich
das ändert
wir müssen auch die automobilkonzerne
mal genau unter die lupe und jetzt
gehört liegen die ich unbedingt dazu die
da zum fanclub der automobilkonzerne
gehört aber ich versuch's mal es gibt
nämlich außer der angesprochenen fort
tschuldigung außerdem angesprochenen
porsche überhaupt keinen
automobilkonzern mehr der überhaupt
hören was in richtung verbrennung noch
macht davon technologieoffenheit zu
reden tut mir leid den antrag hätten sie
vielleicht in der 18 wahlperiode stellen
können aber ihnen hier und heute zu
stellen ist einfach völlig nicht mehr
derzeit angemessen das ist schnee von
gestern es gebe liege möchten sie eine
zwischenfrage bemerkung hast ja ab die
zu lassen
also wir haben in den automobilkonzern
seit langem
eine politik firmenpolitik die sich
darauf eingestellt hat dass ich dort was
ändert es gibt gerade vor rund einer
woche hat vor 300 der großen hersteller
mit zwei standorten in syrien in köln
die erklärt haben
2030 ist schluss mit dem verbrennen
sollen wir jetzt hier gesetze
beschließen oder anträge beschließen die
genau das gegenteil machen ich glaube
das ist auch der falsche weg
technologieoffenheit ist schnee von
gestern das ist abgehakt wichtig ist mit
der dritte punkt das thema
transformation und das wird oft
missverstanden als ein thema weg vom
verbrenner hin zum batterieantrieb wir
brauchen eine industrie ein ein bundle
das wort und transformationen zumindest
was die gewerkschaften dass viele
verbände kammern und so weiter machen da
geht es um einen wandel der
automobilproduktion zu anderen
industrieprodukten zu alternativen zum
auto mobil da gibt es natürlich noch
keine lösung kein grundrezept aber wir
brauchen produktion industrieproduktion
zum beispiel fahrräder solarzellen
straßenbahn und busse die liste lässt
sich beliebig verlängern es geht darum
dass die arbeitsplätze erhalten dann die
gut bezahlt überdurchschnittlich gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze erhalten werden
das den menschen dieser arbeit ist am
ende egal ob sie autos produzieren oder
etwas anderes produzieren es geht darum
dass man den mann geschafft und das ist
transformation und nicht nur der bloße
umgang von zur automobil- und es bleibt
mein letzter bewerbung dazu das kleinste
auch ein verkehrspolitisches ziel im
mittelpunkt wir brauchen eine
verkehrspolitik wohl niemand mehr sagen
kann oder sagen muss sie wurde er sei
auf ein automobil angewiesen es muss
einer politik her wo die alternativen
zum auto konsequent gefördert werden das
heißt nicht dass wir das auto fahren
verbietet der rest von vielleicht 15
oder 20 millionen autos zu sie können
von mir als batterie elektrisch sein
aber die mobilität muss schwerpunktmäßig
über den öffentlichen personennahverkehr
oder den öffentlichen verkehr erfolgen
und dann haben wir auch eine
transformation geschafft die man genau
so bezeichneten vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die bundesregierung spricht jetzt zu
uns der parlamentarische staatssekretär
oliver luksic
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
verkehrssektor steht vor großen
herausforderungen die wir heute
debattieren erlauben sie mir war
eingangs zur aktuellen krise und in der
ukraine und das was das auch für unseren
verkehrsbereich bedeutet ange worte zu
sagen
bundesverkehrsminister wissing ist auf
einladung seines polnischen amtskollegen
sofort an die grenze gefahren mit den
amtskollegen der eu verkehrskommissar in
sich ausgetauscht er hat schnell und
pragmatisch gehandelt man dank geht an
alle im haus im brg vor allem aber auch
an die deutsche bahn die dafür sorgt
dass wir mit flug mit sonderzügen die
menschen schnell in sicherheit bringen
das db cargo eine schienen brücke
aufgebaut hat um die dringend benötigten
hilfsgüter an die grenze zu bringen das
ist schnelle unbürokratische hilfe auch
von den vielen busunternehmern die güter
hinfahren menschen zu uns in sicherheit
bringt das ist eine großartige leistung
auf die wir stolz sein können
natürlich müssen wir auch unsere themen
herangehen und deutschland muss in der
draht vor allem schneller planen
genehmigen und bauen wenn wir heute
darüber reden ein stück schiene in
betrieb zu nehmen kann das bis zu 20
jahre dauern das kann und darf so nicht
bleiben
und deswegen haben wir als erstes auch
und das ist kein einfaches thema wir
haben es aber angegangen weil es
notwendig ist das thema brücken bilanz
und brücken gipfel auf die tagesordnung
gesetzt
wir haben einen neuen focus wir haben
alle brücken nach berechnet ein fokus
auf die traglast also die frage nicht
nur von außen die brücke zu bewerten
sondern eben genau reinzuschauen neu zu
berechnen mit den verkehrsströmen und
deswegen haben wir uns auch auf den
brücken gipfel zusammen mit der
bauwirtschaft mit den umweltverbänden
mit den vielen genehmigungsbehörden
dafür gesorgt und das ist unser ziel
dass wir in unserem land einen
infrastruktur konsens hinbekommen neuen
maßnahmen damit wir schneller den großen
investitionsstau abbau und den wir
vorgefunden haben
wir erhöhen die mittel im haushalt ein
stärkerer fokus auf den halt bis 26 jahr
eine milliarde euro mehr geben wir haben
einen fokus auf das kernnetz wir
priorisieren wahl brücken die
lebensadern unserer wirtschaft sind
deswegen muss das hier funktionieren der
sanierungsstau wird schritt für schritt
abgearbeitet
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das gilt
für alle verkehrsträger schienenwege
wasserstraße radwege digitale
infrastruktur die gigabit strategie
wurde vorgestellt wir haben acht
modellprojekte aus denen wir
schlussfolgern und ziehen wollen vor
allem bin also vernetzt planen bauen und
bewirtschaften und was ganz wichtig ist
das sehen wir gerade jetzt bei der a45
dass wir die verfahren ändern wir haben
setzen hier auf die funktionale
ausschreibung auf den dialog und die
früher einbeziehung aller betroffenen
deswegen haben wir einen
bürgerbeauftragten eingesetzt um die
konflikte ganz früh am anfang zu lösen
damit wir eben nicht in große
rechtsstreitigkeiten reinbekommt das ist
ein neuer ansatz eine politik wo wir zu
hören alle einbinden damit wir schneller
vorankommen bei uns im land
wir müssen mobilität sicher bezahlbar
und nachhaltig gestalten das ist ziel
der bundesregierung das erreichen der
klimaziele aber auch der vision zero
deswegen ist es notwendig jetzt zu
handeln deswegen müssen wir schauen
welche instrumente haben bieten jetzt
sofort wirken das ist natürlich zum
einen die e mobilität und da ist es nun
mal so dass das was wir vorgefunden
haben bei der ladeinfrastruktur nicht
ausreicht deswegen müssen wir die sehr
sehr viel schneller aufbauen wir müssen
jetzt auch das setzen das jetzt
verfügbar ist das ist ein ganz wichtiger
ansatz unserer regierung
und
die wird kolleginnen kollegen folge
motor der kann eben alles vom zweirad
bis zum flugzeug und das wird in zukunft
so nicht es gibt nicht eine
technologielösung die alles kann sondern
verschiedene anwendungen deswegen
fördert unser haus auch technologieoffen
alternative kraftstoffe wasserstoff
batteriegetriebene e mobilität im
bereich der nutzfahrzeuge
1,6 milliarden euro das ist eben der
unterschied wir machen
technologieoffene klimaschutzpolitik und
wir benutzen nicht das wort
technologieoffenheit und beim
klimaschutz nichts zu tun das war auch
schon vergangenheit
diese kollegen und kolleginnen und
kollegen schulden es gibt eine wunsch
nach zwischenfrage aus der abtei möchten
sie den zu lassen na gut ich frage immer
nur einmal eine rede
vielen dank luksic dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen es geht noch mal
ganz konkret um ihre politik gegenüber
synthetischen kraftstoffen und
biokraftstoffen sie haben gerade gesagt
sie fördern die sie wissen ganz genau
dass der synthetische kraftstoffe und
damit auch der komplette
verbrennungsmotor an den flotten
verbrauchsvorgaben
tatsächlich in der eu hängt mit den
aktuellen flotten verbrauchsvorgaben und
der nichtanerkennung von synthetischen
und biokraftstoffen ist gerade eben eine
zukunft des verbrennungsmotors nicht
möglich darf ich ihre rede jetzt so
verstehen wenn sie synthetische
kraftstoffe fordern dass sie sich genau
dafür einsetzen dass diese kraftstoffe
auf die flotten verbräuche der
autohersteller anerkannt werden oder
habe ich das falsch verstanden
der kollege sie wissen dass wir im haus
bei uns das fördern wir haben das eine
reihe an förderprogrammen es gibt
natürlich auch weitere anreizmechanismen
die gelten zb die zwei und drei
detektive und klar ist das ist die
position der gemeinsame position der
bundesregierung dass wir dafür sorgen
dass auch ab 2035
verbrennungsmotoren zugelassen werden
können oder die fahrzeuge mit
verbrennungsmotoren wenn diese nachweis
nicht mit e5 betankt werden also
insofern ist für uns völlig klar wir
machen
technologieoffenen klimaschutz und dazu
gehört auch aber eben nicht nur
alternative kraftstoffe das ist die
position der bundesregierung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen wie gesagt breit fördern wird ein
klimaschutz sofortprogramm geben
technologieoffenheit ist wichtig aber
das hat man ja eben auch noch mal
gemerkt es ist ein sowohl als auch und
weil das eben auch in der debatte
vorgekommen ist also ein weder noch ist
nicht die lösung deswegen können wenn
ich alles was in den letzten zwölf
jahren sich aufgestaut hat in 100 tagen
lösen wir sind aber mit hochdruck
brannten und so freue mich auf die
weitere debatte vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der kollege felix renner hat das wort
für die cdu csu fraktion
ja frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
eine ohne eine gut ausgebaute
infrastruktur
werden wir den wohlstand in unserem land
und übrigens auch keinerlei
klimaschutzziele erreichen und deshalb
müssen wir weitere planungs potenzial in
diesem land heben und mit diesem
antrag den wir heute mit einbringen
warten wir nicht lange ab wir warten
nicht ab irgendwelche gipfel und
arbeitsgruppen getagt haben sondern wir
setzen nahtlos daran fort dass wir vier
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz in der
letzten legislatur auf den weg gebracht
haben übrigens gemeinsam mit der spd
sehr geehrter kollege das hätte ihn
heute nicht geschadet dass zu erwähnen
es ist nämlich ein gemeinsamer erfolg
wichtig dass das problem der spd gerade
in diesen tagen sie freuen sich zu wenig
über das was sie eigentlich auch mal
erreicht haben ich wollte ihnen an
dieser stelle einfach noch mal in
erinnerung und
mit 33 punkten in unserem antrag zur
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
und setzten die erwartungshaltung an die
bundesregierung dass wir den erhalt und
den ausbau der infrastruktur
beschleunigen dass wir aber für die
menschen dem individuellen
mobilitätsbedürfnisse auch gerecht
werden und ist ja schön wenn heute die
einen die kollegin von den grünen und
auch von der spd und linke sowie sowie
dann gehört haben es braucht kein auto
mehr und so weiter meine damen und
herren 60 prozent der bevölkerung lebt
in ländlichen raum und wir nicht wer
nicht zulässt dass es auch in zukunft
noch straßenbau in diesem land geht der
verkennt die wirklichkeit wir haben da
einen anderen weg
und zur wahrheit gehört doch es sind die
projekte vor ort die
frustrierten für politikverdrossenheit
symbolisch stehen mal über jahrzehnte
hinweg geplant wird und eben nicht
gebaut werden konnte dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger in uns allen
abgeordneten aus den wahlkreisen sagen
da kann es eigentlich sein dass man 50
jahre für ein straßenbauprojekt für eine
ortsumfahrung braucht das geht doch
allzu lange wenn wir uns da einig sind
da muss man auch mal klar benennen woran
es liegt herr kollege eine zwischenfrage
aus der fraktion die linke möchten sie
die gerne zu lassen herr nutze
und hetze sie können ja jetzt die maske
abnehmen und ansonsten wir es gut über
die nase
lieber kollege schreiber sie haben
gerade sinngemäß behauptet dass wir
irgendwie das auto ab - würden sie bitte
zur kenntnis nehmen dass ich in meiner
vorherigen räte gerade gesagt habe dass
ich mich eine qualitative unterschied
dass niemand mehr darauf angewiesen sein
muss ein auto zu fahren das impliziert
diese aussage das ist ja wohl noch
fahren darf also es will ja niemand
irgendwas verbieten es geht darum das
ist auch bei mir im saarland ganz viele
menschen gibt die moment vollkommen
nachvollziehbar sagen sie kam keine
andere möglichkeit als mit dem auto von
a nach b zu kommen diesen zustand müssen
wir würden das hat nichts damit zu tun
wenn wir diesen missstand aufheben
wollen dass wir das auto frank verbieten
das ist völliger unsinn es tut mir leid
dann ist es okay dass man gerade stellen
wir hatten uns anders verstanden weil
ich sage ihnen ganz offen sie natürlich
immer wieder und auch in den ausschüssen
klipp und klar zum ausdruck bringen dass
sie die mobilität der menschen auch
vorschreiben wollen und ich sage ihnen
ich bin schon der meinung ich bin ein
freiheitsliebender mensch jeder soll
sich so bewegen wie er will aber
derjenige der im ländlichen raum auf
sein auto angewiesen ist sollte es auch
in zukunft fahren können war das geht
auch mit sozialer teilhabe einher und
meinen wenn ihm eine rede fortsetzen
darf ich möchte an die bundesregierung
sagen ich habe ja manchmal sogar mitleid
auch mit herrn wissing und luksic und
der staatsekretär teurer war zum
beispiel neulich bei mir im wahlkreis am
hochrhein wir haben dort die 98 besucht
das war ein guter termin er hat sich den
bürgern gestellt wir haben einigkeit
darüber was ist dann passiert was ist
dann passiert in den nächsten tagen wie
hermann aus baden württemberg schaltet
sich zu wort vom frei vom schreibtisch
und erklärt das ende der hochrhein
autobahn a98 sagt alle planungen von
bundesverkehrswegeplan in baden
württemberg kommen auf dem brühl wir
wollen keine straßen mehr bauen ja meine
damen und herren wir müssen es doch mal
beim namen nennen überall wo man mal ein
stück weit vorankommen will sind die
grünen vor ort dies wieder torpediert
und wir haben noch heute in der rede
gehört und deshalb ist es auch eine
aufforderung von der unionsfraktion an
die bundesregierung sie haben im
koalitionsvertrag rein geschrieben dass
sie den bundesverkehrswegeplan in gänze
mit den projekten überprüfen wollen in
wahrheit wissen wir dass sie sich in den
koalitionsverhandlungen natürlich auch
speziell von der grünen seite da viel
haben anhören lassen müssen aber wir
bitten sie wirklich machen sie das nicht
gehen sie da den grünen nicht auf den
leim eine überprüfung des
bundesverkehrswegeplans führt zu allem
zu einem slim ich nicht zur planungs
beschleunigung in deutschland sondern
dass viele viele projekte hinten runter
fallen und das ist noch alles länger
geht sie haben uns an der seite wenn es
darum geht den bundesverkehrswegeplan in
dieser sache auch umzusetzen meine damen
und herren wir haben heute einen antrag
eingebracht wo wir natürlich als
parlament das instrument der planungs
genehmigung mehr nutzen möchten wir
wollen rechtsverbindliche standards bei
den genehmigungsverfahren setzen wir
können das nationale naturschutzrecht
auf die vorhaben des unionsrechts
begrenzen wir können die chancen der
digitalisierung nutzen wir können eine
stichtagsregelung einführen wir können
ein bonus malus regeln für die
bauverträge verbindlich prüfen das sind
alles beispiele was man machen kann aber
zeigen sie liebe regierungsfraktionen
dass sie wollen stimmen sie unseren
antrag heute zu es ist eine fortsetzung
von vier gesetzen die wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode mit den
sozialdemokraten auf den weg gebracht
haben weil es uns ernst ist bei der
planungs beschleunigung in deutschland
wie sagt felix schreiner cdu csu
fraktionschefs ausschuss und hier geht
es noch mal kurz unsere beiden anträge
die cdu csu fraktion heute eingebracht
lassen in dieser woche habt ihr
redebeitrag eine fragt sich ja bei
fragen wobei verkehrsprojekt keine mehr
wenn man direkt und persönlich aber auch
mit klimapolitischen aus prävention
danach bei diesem thema erfolgen das
könnte jetzt auch sein wenn eine
fraktion insgesamt angesprochen wird
dass eine kurzintervention erfolgt habe
ich aber jetzt keine anmeldung dazu
allerdings ist es ja auch so dass nach
einem noch einen redebeitrag durch die
grünen fast jetzt ja alles klar das ist
dann verstanden vielen dank dann
erläuterung
der welt allerdings gehört aber jetzt
kann es weitergehen in der ausfall
hatte von juli für die sozialdemokraten
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe kollegen
der cdu csu ich muss schon sagen ihre
reden heute hier fallen deutlich hinter
ihren anträgen zurück und riefen nur
soviel theologie und ich will an der
stelle auf den grünen anbieten dass ich
auch in baden württemberg über neue
mehrheiten reden können wenn sie in
neuen koalitionspartner brauchen
wir müssen doch zur kenntnis nehmen dass
das umweltbundesamt diese woche auch
noch mal festgestellt hat dass der
verkehrssektor seine sektor ziele bei
der co2 einsparung nicht erreicht hat
und auch wenn wir uns die
kraftstoffpreise anschauen müssen sie
uns eigentlich noch mehr ermutigen den
weg für mehr klimaschutz im verkehr
entschlossen voran zu bringen das ist
klimapolitisch richtig das ist
sicherheitspolitisch
notwendig aber es ist auch ökonomisch
sinnvoll vorgestern kam die nachricht
dass elektroautofahrer bis zu 60 prozent
günstiger unterwegs sind aktuell als
diddy verbrennungsmotor fahren man
könnte fast meinen die mineralölkonzerne
ferne treibt mit ihrer abzocke an der
tankstelle ihre eigene
bedeutungslosigkeit voran
ich würde mich auch freuen wenn sie ihre
auch durchaus sinnvollen vorschläge für
mehr klimaschutz im verkehr an ihrem
ministerpräsidenten im saarland
entschuldigung noch ministerpräsidenten
im saarland auch mal schicken würden
damit er sich damit auseinandersetzen
kann wie man transformation vor ort
umsetzen kann zum beispiel ladesäule
infrastruktur ausbauen statt peinliche
videos an der tankstelle zu drehen das
hilft nämlich niemand
und wer sich schon mal dabei sind
wenn sie schon mal dabei sind schicken
sie doch das papier auch an herrn söder
in cc damit er aufhört beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien auf der bremse zu
stehen denn wenn wir strom basierte
kraftstoff us- oder elektroautos wollen
egal welche technologie alles braucht
strom und zwar sehr viel davon und davon
gibt es in süddeutschland eben nicht
sehr viel und besonders nicht
erneuerbaren sich fordern
technologieoffenheit aber die
autoindustrie hat sich doch entschieden
und fast alle autokonzerne setzen
vorrangig auf e-mobilität für die
nächsten zehn jahre wie kollegin herr
spanien meldet sich wieder und mit all
ihren kräften
dazu komme ich jetzt sicher
technologieoffenheit aber die
autoindustrie hat sich entschieden und
wir als eine gute ampel koalition
unterstützen die autoindustrie auf ihrem
weg zur e mobilität in dem wir die
infrastruktur dafür bereitstellen das
nennt sich dann gute industriepolitik
infrastruktur schaffen
infrastruktur schaffen die innovation
fördern ziel ist es 15 millionen
vollelektrische pkw bis 20.30 und dafür
braucht es da haben sie recht in ihrem
antrag
halbleiterproduktion und batteriezellen
produktion deshalb ist es besonders
schön dass gerade diese woche zwei große
standort entscheidungen angekündigt
wurden einmal in magdeburg werden große
kapazitäten für halbleiter produktion
aufgebaut und in schleswig holstein eine
giga factory für batteriezellen
produktion und recycling
und man muss sich aber vor augen führen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen aus
süddeutschland dass diese
standort-entscheidungen norddeutschland
unter anderem begründet wurden weil dort
die verfügbarkeit für erneuerbare
energien vorhanden ist und das führt uns
noch mal ganz klar vor augen die
trägheit beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien in bayern und baden württemberg
wird zu einem echten standort nachteil
in zukunft werden
also die industrie hat erkannt
elektromobilität ist unschlagbar
effiziente immer mehr verbraucher fassen
auch vertrauen in diese technologie was
die langen wartezeiten auch bei elektro
autos zeigen
der hochlauf wird exponentiell laufen
wie beim smartphone und wir als
koalition unterstützen das weil wir die
unabhängigkeit von öl basierten schritt
langfristig auch der beste weg ist um
sicherzustellen dass mobilität bezahlbar
bleibt durchgehend sein
[Applaus]
leif erik holm hat scott für die
fraktion erst der wirtschaftspolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte bürger liebe kollegen es ist ja
wirklich schön anzusehen wie die union
jetzt eine position nach der anderen
räumt sie fordern jetzt ja sie fordern
jetzt in teilen genau das gegenteil von
dem was sie in 16 jahren regierung
vermurkst haben das ist ziemlich klar
sie schreiben jetzt in ihrem antrag zur
automobilindustrie der verbrennungsmotor
wird teils vorschnell generell als
klimasünder dargestellt die
elektromobilität wird hingegen als
königsweg beschrieben diese kritik ist
vollkommen richtig die teilen wir wir
predigen dass sogar schon seit jahren
aber es hat sie in der regierung nicht
die bohne interessiert es war nämlich
ihre politik unter wirtschaftsminister
altmaier klammer auf cdu klammer zu die
dazu geführt hat dass unsere
autoindustrie den bach runtergeht sie
können hier also nicht und schulz
knabenliebe sie haben unter merkel
jahrelang einzig und allein auf autos
gesetzt in der korona locker und krise
haben sie massive kaufprämien ausgerufen
nicht für moderne verbrenner nur nur für
strom und das hat überhaupt nichts mit
technologieoffenheit zu tun von der sie
hier im antrag sprechen und ich habe
noch gar nicht davon gesprochen wo
eigentlich der strom für die strom
herkommen soll und diese künstliche
bevorzugung der batterie autos sie in
gang gesetzt haben die schadet unserem
standort deutschland
und wir sehen es doch die produktion
sinkt stärker als in anderen
industriebereichen die beschäftigung
sinkt besonders bei den zulieferern der
rutsch in richtung ausland hat längst
begonnen und dafür haben wir von anfang
an gewarnt dass es ihr werk und wer
freut sich eigentlich über die riesigen
subventionen ist jetzt gibt das sind
ausgerechnet die wenigen die sich die
besonders teuren e autos leisten können
so freuen sich die tesla fahrer dass
ihre neuwagen nach sechs monaten
richtung dänemark verkaufen können und
dann sogar noch mehr als die neu preis
erzielen sie machen noch einen gewinn
dabei wenn das erstmal bekannt wird wird
es jeder tun ich freu mich schon drauf
das wird wirklich spannend und das zeigt
aber den ganzen irrsinn dieser
subventionitis die sie betreiben ich
finde das geld könnten wir wirklich
sinnvoller ausgeben schaurig die preise
an der tankstelle an
wer soll das denn noch bezahlen die
milliarden euro die die bundesregierung
für diesen ganzen premiere klimbim
ausgegeben hat die hätten jetzt dabei
helfen können zb die mehrwertsteuer an
der temporär zu senken und eine solche
erleichterung brauchen die bürger jetzt
wirklich dringend
liebe und sie fordern wie im antrag auch
das unterschreibe ich sofort kein
unwiderrufliches enddatum für den
verbrennungsmotor festzulegen ja aber
lassen sie mich auch hier ihrem
gedächtnis auf die sprünge helfen es war
ihr parteifreund söder der getrieben von
schwarz-grünen regierungstreuen den
verbrennungsmotor bis 2035 beerdigen
wollte merken sie was ein kartoffelroder
kartoffeln man kann ihnen nichts mehr
glauben sie haben ihre glaubwürdigkeit
längst verspielt
zusammengefasst es stehen durchaus
sinnvolle punkte in ihrem antrag aber
sie können den großen widerspruch darin
nicht auflösen im gegenteil er wird hier
richtig deutlich wollen sie nun
technologieoffenheit oder wollen sie die
transformationen beschleunigen beides
zusammenpasst nicht das ist wie ein
bisschen schwanger und meine frau sagt
das geht nicht liebe kollegen audio.de
während vier jahren womöglich jamaika
weg zum vergessen sich kommt zum ende
versöhnt denn wenn ich vier jahren
ermöglicht jamaika winkt und vergessen
sie sowieso wieder alle guten vorsätze
und lassen sich von den grünen auslasten
fahrrad setzen wer mit seinem auto mobil
bleiben möchte wird besser gleich die
autofahrer partei die fdp dankeschön
leif erik holm basis für die auf die
fraktionen deren wirtschaftspolitischer
sprecher würden die nächste hier in der
aussprache in diesen beiden anträge der
cdu csu fraktion ist zusammenhänge
90/die grünen und es ist ihre erste rede
im deutschen bundestag
cdu sehr geehrte damen und herren zu
kollege schreiber möchte ich sagen es
ist keine beliebigkeit einer regierung
die bedarfsplan überprüfung vorzunehmen
sondern es ist gesetzlich vorgeschrieben
er berate abgeordnete die unionsfraktion
fordert in ihrem antrag die
vermeintlichen planungs beschleunigungen
der letzten wahlperiode aus unserer
sicht zu unrecht sie setzen auf
scheinlösungen während die wirksamen
maßnahmen 16 jahren kanzlerschaft gar
nicht angepackt wurden der schwerpunkt
der csu-minister lag vor allem beim
straßenbau mit dem fokus auf bayern die
bestehende verkehrsinfrastruktur haben
sie dagegen völlig vernachlässigt marode
und unpassierbare brücken sind ein
ergebnis dieses politik versorgungs
jetzt tut sie so als seien diese
missstände vor allem ein problem
mangelnder planungs beschleunigung dabei
waren ist ihre falschen
verkehrspolitischen prioritäten von
denen sie nun versuchen abzulenken ein
weiteres beispiel die mittel für den aus
und neubau ins schienennetz waren unter
csu minister auf ein jämmerliches niveau
von etwas mehr als eine milliarde euro
jährlich abgesunken das reichte auch im
europäischen vergleich nur für einen
hinteren platz besonders deutlich wird
die vernachlässigung der schiene bei den
verbindungen zu unseren nachbarländern
nicht einmal die elektrifizierung von
eisenbahnstrecken haben sie hinbekommen
seit 1998 versprechen wir zum beispiel
tschechien die elektrifizierung der
strecken nürnberg prag bis heute fahren
nur dieselloks auf dieser strecke und
das soll bis 2028 so bleiben das ist ein
verkehrs- und klimapolitisches
armutszeugnis
beim thema planungsverfahren treten für
uns vier anforderungen erstens der
zügige verfahrensablauf zweitens die
rechtzeitige beteiligung von bürgerinnen
hohe standards beim natur- und
umweltschutz und viertens absolute
rechtssicherheit für die vorhabenträger
legen wir diese kriterien einmal an das
von ihnen auf den weg gebrachten
maßnahmen gesetz an ich greife die
rechtssicherheit heraus und frage wie
rechtssicher ist denn ein gesetz das die
eu kommission ein vertrag für die dass
die eu kommission ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren eingeleitet
hat das gesetz beschneidet bürgerinnen
und bürgern sowie umweltverbänden ihre
möglichkeiten gegen rechtsverstöße
vorgehen zu können das ist eine
missachtung der aarhus konvention was
die eu-kommission völlig zu recht
moniert dass maßnahmen gesetzt in seiner
bisherigen fassung bringt keine
beschleunigung sondern maximale
rechtsunsicherheit sie erweisen der
planungs beschleunigung damit einen
bärendienst die ursachen von überlangen
planungsverfahren liegen oft weniger bei
den verfahrensregeln sondern vor allem
am personalmangel und früherer
sparpolitik personal fehlt auf allen
ebenen der planung und genehmigung bei
den planungsbüros in den entsprechenden
abteilungen der vorhabenträger bei den
anhörungs und genehmigungsbehörden und
schließlich auch bei den
verwaltungsgerichten der antrag der
union bietet übrigens keine lösung zum
problem fachpersonal an wert die
kolleginnen und kollegen wir werden bei
den kommenden haushaltsberatungen darauf
achten dass die personalausstattung der
genehmigungsbehörden mit der wachsenden
investitionslinie schritt hält und
entsprechend aufgestockt wird die
schiene ist ein rückgrat der
verkehrswende deshalb müssen wir vor
allem den bau von schienenprojekten und
weiteren vorhaben des öffentlichen
verkehrs beschleunigen den
koalitionsvertrag der ein
beschleunigungs kommission ziehen daher
schnell aufgegleist werden dazu gehört
auch die digitalisierung von planungs
und genehmigungsprozessen prozessen wie
sie im ampel vertrag festgehalten wurde
wie kann es im jahr 2022 eigentlich sein
dass wir die deutsche bahn auf das
digitale planen mit building information
modeling verpflichten dass die fertigen
unterlagen dann aber in papierform an
das eisenbahnbundesamt weitergehen
lassen sie mich abschließend noch etwas
zur einordnung ihres antrages sagen den
ich nur vor dem hintergrund der
landtagswahlen erklären kann sie wollen
die umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung bei
der planung von verkehrsinfrastrukturen
begrenzen und das naturschutzrecht
beschneiden und dieses alte denken
leitet ihren gesamten antrag natur und
umweltschutz sind eigentlich ballast
klimaschutz und artenschutz sind aber
zwei seiten einer medaille
und wir bündnisgrüne lassen es nicht zu
denn kurz vor landtagswahlen versucht
werden soll das eine gegen das andere
auszuspielen
sorgfalt vor schnelligkeit heißt es in
einer redewendung angesichts der
herausforderungen der klimakrise müssen
wir beides unter einen hut bekommen ich
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit im
deutschen bundestag saß vorher auch
schon mal niedersächsischen landtag ist
dann im september über die landesliste
in
niedersachsen in den bundestag
eingezogen ihr wahlkreis ist oldenburg
ammerland
nächster redner henning rehbaum für die
cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
sperrung der rahmede talbrücke ist ein
weckruf für so manchen hier im haus wie
viele jahre mussten wir uns als union
anhören dass man kein geld mehr in
autobahn stecken sollte
dieselben kräfte die uns als union für
zu viel geld für die straßen kritisiert
haben stellen sich jetzt hin und werfen
uns vor wir hätten zu wenig investiert
das ist absurd
ich habe selber 2017 die
koalitionsverhandlungen für den verkehr
in nordrhein westfalen mit geführt
kollege berkant kollegin slavik nach 46
jahren spd geführte landesregierung mit
einer ganz kleinen unterbrechung und wir
haben in die schubladen geguckt des
ministeriums und da haben wir keine
baureife brückenplanung gefunden wenn
sie dieses fass aufmachen können sie nur
verlieren rot grün wollte überhaupt gar
keinen straßenbau sie haben gelder nach
berlin zurück geben müssen weil nichts
fertig geplant war selbst
verkehrsminister groschek spd hat sich
beschwert über eine durch grüne
verkehrspolitik bei der nichts fertig
wird
die cdu-geführte und gemeinsam mit der
fdp gut organisierte landesregierung
nimmt mittlerweile gelder aus dem bund
die andere bundesländer zurückgeben und
wir haben heute einen rekordhaushalt in
nordrhein westfalen für schienenwege für
den straßenbau für reaktivierung von
schienenstrecken für den öpnv für
fahrrad wir reden wir machen
unter der union ist der verkehrs etat
für straße schiene fahrrad wasserstraße
des bundes nahezu
verdoppelt worden dazu vier
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz die jetzt
konsequent umzusetzen sind beim
infrastrukturbau haben wir kein
erkenntnisproblem meine damen und herren
nein wir haben ein krasses
umsetzungsproblem das gilt für straße
schiene oder radwege genauso wie für
windkraft solar parks pipelines oder
wasserstoff projekte jeder weiß das
problem sind die skier ende ein
planungs- und genehmigungsverfahren 30
jahre für eine bahnstrecke zehn jahre
für ein windrad acht jahre für einen rat
schnell weg fünf jahre für den ersatzbau
einer autobahnbrücke wir brauchen
massive beschleunigung weit über die
vier guten gesetzespakete der großen
koalition hinaus
wichtig ist auch den artenschutz zu
modernisieren und das wohlgemerkt nicht
nur bei straßenbauprojekten hunderte
windräder in ganz deutschland können
seit jahren nicht gebaut werden weil
etwa der rote milan oder der uhu in der
nachbarschaft gesichtet wurde der
nrw-landesverband erneuerbare energien
sah sich letztes jahr wegen
überbordender artenschutz klagen
gezwungen vor der zentrale des nabu in
düsseldorf zu demonstrieren so weit
musste ist erstmal kommen und eine
jahrelange hängepartie für die menschen
in lüdenscheid wegen ein paar
fledermäusen im abgängigen brückenkörper
das kann man außerhalb der parlamente
behörden und ngo es niemandem erklären
wir müssen artenschutz planungsrecht und
klimaschutz miteinander versöhnen die
verfahren müssen schneller werden und
das muss man wollen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der ampel man muss alte
glaubenssätze über bord werfen und zwar
konsequent
letzter punkt warum braucht man
eigentlich jahrelange
planfeststellungsverfahren für
ersatzneubauten von brücken die an
derselben stelle entstehen denn auf der
a45 wie bei hunderten weiteren bahn und
autobahnbrücken ändert sich faktisch
nichts da steht heute eine brücke und da
wird auch in zukunft eine brücke stehen
da gibt es nur eins bagger bestellen
stadt fledermäuse zählen
die vier beschleunigungs pakete der
gruppe müssen umgesetzt werden heute
packt die union noch eins obendrauf zur
abstimmung für klimaschutz und
alltagstaugliche mobilität herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
und eine volk nach der anderen wir haben
den wettbewerb der ersten reden wir
freuen uns drauf und zwar spricht für
die fdp fraktion ist der kollege jürgen
lenders
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir werden bei all dem was wir tun stets
die technologieoffenheit im auge
behalten und wir werden dabei an die
menschen denken die menschen in den
urbanen gebieten in den ländlichen
räumen und da schauen wir uns nicht auch
alle verkehrsträger mitzudenken da
gehört das fahrrad dazu da gehört er das
auto dazu mit seinem verbrennungsmotor
da gehört die schiene dazu meine damen
und herren wenn jetzt hier die kollegen
und kolleginnen von union die frage nach
den puls aufmachen kann ich nur sagen
wir müssen darum und darum uns kümmern
dass wir möglichst früh möglichst die
produktion von i fuels hochfahren und
meine damen und herren dann würde sich
so manche kritik von ihnen auch
erledigen
meine damen und herren was infrastruktur
bedeuten kann für menschen gerade nehmen
wir das beispiel lüdenscheid um pendler
wo anwohner wo unternehmer davon
betroffen sind dass er jetzt vom
durchgangsverkehr belastet sind meine
damen und herren dass es nahezu eine
katastrophe für die menschen vor ort
nehmen wir mal die salzbach talbrücke in
wiesbaden da war das nicht nur die
autobahn da war das auch die gleich die
schieneninfrastruktur die auch damit
erleben ist eine landeshauptstadt war
über monate
abgeschnitten sozusagen von dem pendler
strom meine damen und herren das können
wir und das werden wir so nicht
akzeptieren
jetzt mal zu ihrem antrag
geschätzte union das sind 33 punkte die
sie hier aufgeschrieben haben das sind 1
gleich eigentlich 33 punkte eine
aufzählt ihre eigenen unzulänglichkeit
weil sie haben doch in den letzten
jahren regiert
[Applaus]
es steht ja auch nicht alles nur falsch
ist und da sind ja durchaus auch punkte
dabei die haben wir auch selber stunden
gefordert das ist
gibt es auch punkte da kann man auch
darüber diskutieren aber herr kollege
schreiner 1 möchte ich ihnen dann schon
auch nochmals sagen dass wir die
bedarfsprüfung die auf einem gesetz fuß
was sie selber gemacht haben jetzt
ignorieren sollen also wir sollen jetzt
ein gesetz was sie selber auf den weg
gebracht haben ignorieren meine damen
das kann's ja wohl wirklich nicht
und so mancher punkt ist durchaus zu
diskutieren der reform hat ja auch
gerade schon auf den punkt 2 zuletzt
reflektiert aus die haben antrag meine
damen und herren es gibt ja durchaus
auch in unseren reihen
personen die darüber nachdenken was die
frage was ist noch verhältnismäßig und
wie inwieweit ist die
die frage der und der
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung ein
hemmschuh aber herr kollege das
hauptproblem ist hier dass der nationale
gesetzgeber den verzicht auf
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung nicht
alleine entscheiden kann hier ist es
zwingend notwendig dass euro europäische
recht zu ändern so einfach wie sie sich
das machen geht es nun mal nicht
und herr kollege was sie einfach sich
auch den vorwurf gefallen lassen müssen
wenn man ihren antrag liest hat man
nicht den eindruck dass sie über die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung mal
nachdenken wollen sondern dass sie sie
einfach komplett schleifen wollen und
das machen wir nicht
weinen
viele ihrer punkte sind reine
symbolpolitik nehmen wir mal die
forderung das vergaberecht zu
überarbeiten das klingt ja ganz schön
aber allein in dem bereich wo die länder
dafür zuständig sind ja meine
kolleginnen und kollegen da haben wir
überhaupt gar keine
gesetzgebungskompetenz
und wenn sie solche anträge hier
vorlegen sollten sie zur ehrlichkeit
aussagen dass wir das überhaupt hier von
hier nicht regeln können meine damen und
herren
absolut
absurd ist die forderung artikel zwei
ebenen vergaberichtlinien meine damen
und herren auch wenn sie in den letzten
16 jahren
regiert haben den verfall der
infrastruktur kann man sicherlich nicht
dann mit dringlichkeit begründen das
problem ist längst vorher schon bekannt
gewesen
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen dass sie dann auch noch
eine direktvergabe fordern in
millionenhöhe da kann ich sie nur
vorwarnen solch einen weg zu beschreiten
das öffnet der korruption tür und tor
meine damen und herren wir als koalition
wären einen anderen weg gehen vielen
dank
für die fdp fraktion auch eine der neuen
abgeordneten katrin göring-eckardt hat
das besagt in dieser debatte doch einige
neue also in die
verkehrs im verkehrsausschuss da gibt es
tatsächlich einige neue gesichter jugend
lenders gehört dazu wie auch seine
vorrednerin jürgen lenders lange im
hessischen landtag ist gewählt über die
fdp landesliste und sein wahlkreis ist
fulda so viel zeit muss sein nächster
redner kw mansouri für die
sozialdemokraten
meine damen und herren ich muss sagen
fünf seiten zum thema planungs
beschleunigung und zeichnet von
alexander dobrindt haben mich dann im
ergebnis noch ein bisschen mehrheit hat
als ihre aktuelle stunde zum klimaschutz
natürlich fragt man sich bei
interessierter lektüre warum haben sie
das denn nicht in ihrer regierungszeit
gemacht ich kann ihnen sagen weil die
größten bremsen für die mobilität und
energie wende in diesem land in den
letzten 16 jahren nicht rotmilan
einwendung und verwaltungsprozessen
sondern dobrindt altmaier und scheuer
meine damen und herren
und die
defizite in planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren wollen sie jetzt
im fingerstreich auf fünf seiten lösen
vor allem beim aktionismus da macht die
union auf der oppositionsbank jetzt so
richtig tempo nur sind das eben keine
seriösen vorschläge ein stein sagt alles
muss so einfach wie möglich sein aber
eben nicht einfacher und ich will einige
herausforderungen unter dem stichwort
planungs beschleunigung der erstens
weniger papier und digitaler behörden
abstimmung nach zweitens da wo es
sinnvoll ist sollten unterschiedliche
verwaltungseinheiten parallel zueinander
planen und nicht nacheinander drittens
es braucht vertrauen und akzeptanz und
behördliche entscheidungen dafür muss
die öffentlichkeit möglichst früh
einbezogen werden viertens und das ist
eine schwierige baustelle wir müssen den
prüfungsaufwand für behörden und
gerichte reduzieren die begründung eines
bebauungsplans bei mir in meiner stadt
frankfurt hat etwa 100 seiten für die
genehmigung einer windenergieanlage
können sie einen kleinen
besprechungsraum mit leitz ordner füllen
für ein großes
planfeststellungsverfahren reicht das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht aus dem
artenschutzrecht müssen wir prüfungs
schritte standardisieren man muss nicht
in jedem verfahren bei adam und eva
anfangen weil es um den schutz von
populationen und nicht von individuen
geht
fünftens
wir wollen den planungsprozess strafen
soweit möglich müssen einwendungen die
bis zu einem bestimmten stichtag nicht
erhoben sind für das weitere verfahren
ausgeschlossen sein im fachjargon nennt
man das perkussion und 6 wir wollen die
verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit in die lage
versetzen schneller zu einem verfahrens
ende zu kommen meine früheren
verwaltungsrechts professoren reimer und
eifert würden sich jetzt sicher freuen
wenn ich das alles vertiefe dafür reicht
unsere zeit heute aber nicht aus denn
wir reden hier meine damen und herren
über nichts geringeres als die größte
verwaltungsmodernisierung seit gründung
der bundesrepublik und das wollen sie
jetzt einfach mal auf fünf seiten müssen
die hatten 16 jahre zeit dafür meine
damen und herren
und in diesen 16 jahren haben sie den
verwaltungs grundsatz der
wirtschaftlichkeit und sparsamkeit vor
allem dann hoch gehalten wenn es nicht
um in die röhre ministerbüros ging aber
die großen planfeststellungsverfahren
meine damen und herren die bearbeiten
sich eben nicht von selbst sondern
menschen bearbeiten die im weswegen ist
das thema personalmangel auch eines das
wir jetzt auf die agenda packen werden
wir meine damen und herren werden diese
dinge jetzt ressort übergreifend angehen
weil es gerade in diesen tagen auch
darum geht zu zeigen dass demokratische
rechtsstaaten etwas bewegen können und
wir setzen auch auf einen bundeskanzler
der sich für diese themen im europarecht
stark macht die ersten ampel gesetze
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen werden
wir hier in kürze diskutieren und ich
bin gespannt was die csu in bayern bis
dahin beschleunigt hat wo unternehmen
abwandern weil planungs beschleunigung
bei ihnen nämlich vor allem aus einem
stoff besteht nämlich heißer luft ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
juli war das für die spd fraktion
und die cdu/csu-fraktion die hier ja die
antragstellende fraktion ist die hitzige
debatte ärzten reden begrüße ich jetzt
und initiierte martina eng und auch eine
abgeordnete mit ihrer ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag hat
die bundestags vizepräsidentin gerade
angekündigt martina engel hat kopf ist
das für die cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sicher erreichen auch sie in diesen
tagen aber seit wochen und monate die
hilferufe von bürgerinnen und bürger
aber auch von betrieben doch endlich
etwas gegen die explodierenden
spritpreise an den tankstellen zu
unternehmen auf die bisher ungenügend
die reaktion der bundesregierung will
ich an dieser stelle gar nicht erst
eingehen es ist längst überfällig zu
hahn hin besser heute als morgen schnee
und unbürokratisch und dieser hilferuf
zeigt doch eins was für die zukunft der
mobilität der verkehrspolitik
entscheidend ist mobilität muss für alle
bezahlbar bleiben und
erlaubt mir dieser stelle einen kurzen
einwurf
feministische debatten wer jetzt wie
entlastet wird ob männer oder frauen
mehr auto fahren und entsprechen was
zurück bekommen müssen das ist doch
haare sträuben das ist ein schlag ins
gesicht für betroffene unternehmer aber
auch für familien für bürgerinnen und
bürger insbesondere in den ländlichen
wahlkreisen es ist völlig absurd und
dieser stelle völlig fehl am platz und
damit dieses ziel erreicht werden kann
fordern wir heute in unserem antrag die
bundesregierung auf bei der umsetzung
der klimaschutzziele
technologieoffen aber auch ideologiefrei
zu handeln und wenn wir die debatten in
der letzten halben stunde betrachten
steckt so viel ideologie in der
argumentation viele redner und das
bringt uns für die zukunft nicht weiter
wenn wir das ziel erreichen wollen